uh Mr Mayor we it's really worrying that
those eight uh protesters from Republic
were arrested and then um bailed and and
uh you said that Bell it was all
canceled no further action same
happening for the um volunteer the night
Stars volunteers this is people uh being
locked up for the duration of the event
and um and actually it turns out that
there was you know these are people who
had been engaging with the police there
was it's really chilling for
people who want to protest in London and
that is a human right it is part of our
culture in London to go to Peaceful
protests and these are people who are
locked up for about 16 hours it's a
traumatic experience being arrested and
locked up and it is really worrying to
hear that that has been happening on our
streets in London did you get any
impression from the briefings you had
beforehand that there was going to be
this approach of locking people up
um for such long periods with such low
tolerance
it's because there are concerns raised
that I uh wrote to the commissioner and
both the commissioner and I've made our
letters public to reassure the public in
relation to
uh the police response and the questions
uh that I have are clearly
in our culture to protest it's enshrined
in legislation article attorney is quite
clear of the Human Rights Act in
relation to the right to protest and
that includes protesting when it's not
the most popular issue in the world by
the way and nobody's suggesting setting
the police on uh that you can suspend
the right to protest when there is a
coronation and there was also protests
taking place over that that weekend I
think the issue is if they're a lesson
to be learned in relation to the new the
two new acts the 23 Act and the 22 act
in particular and that's why I've asked
the commissioner for the operational
review to be made public so the public
can be reassured that any lessons that
can be learned should be learned
I'm glad that that's going to be made
public now I want to pick up on the
Westminster city council night Stars
volunteers because that was a really
shocking episode
um when you ask the commissioner what
briefing there was for officers about
the local Partnerships he said the
briefings would not include local
matters like the deployment of night
star volunteers but yesterday at the
home Affairs select committee Susie
Melvin one of those night Stars
volunteers who was arrested
said that the officer who arrested her
said they were specifically looking for
the night star's volunteers so it sounds
like the night Stars volunteers were
being targeted
if the Mets say they were not briefed on
the night stars and yet they were still
looking for them on the night that just
feels really worrying
um are you satisfied with the
commissioner's explanation about the
night stars and their arrest
I think there's a difference of versions
from Westminster and the volunteers and
the police and I think the temporary
assistance commissioner twist has agreed
to meet with the volunteers in the
council to resolve the issue of the
difference of versions because you're
right that has apparently different
versions coming from the police the
volunteers and the council I mean I
think the the offer from AC twist is a
sensible one and I hope they all need to
discuss this
I hope they'll do more than just discuss
it I hope they'll learn some lessons
from it because I mean the person giving
evidence yesterday she would have known
that the police will have body worn
video of the interaction she won't have
made made up
um what what she gave in in evidence
yesterday I just finally want to
um uh ask whether you are going to Lobby
the government to repeal this new
legislation you've mentioned that you're
concerned about the new legislation
particularly uh the public order act
um are you going to Lobby to try and get
that repealed no there are parts of the
legislation that I support particularly
in relation to National infrastructure
I'm concerned about section two
I'm concerned about
um the block on Provisions the
definition of what a lock on equipment
is you'll have seen the confusion in
relation to the public and understanding
what is doomed to be locked on and not
particularly when it relates to going
equipped to uh lock on I think it's
important for the police to uh undertake
a proper debrief of what happened this
weekend on operational review you'll be
where the first time the 23 legislation
was used was at the coronation
and it's really important the lessons uh
art learned I'll learn because you'll be
aware some of those uh against him there
was no further action uh the concern was
they had equipment going equipped to
lock-ons there are questions in relation
to section two in the definition I think
Mr Mayor there are huge questions about
um what going equipped to lock on
actually means um but I'm going to leave
my questions there thank you very much
thank you
thank you very much
we now move to the questions on the
priority order paper
each group on the assembly is allocated
an amount of time to ask their questions
that is proportionate to their size
the first question
is is number
1600 and it concerns floating bus stops
from assembly member best
thank you chair I want all of London's
infrastructure to be as safe as possible
for all Road users I've asked tfl to
review the data on collisions around bus
stop bypasses to evaluate if any changes
should be considered and it's generally
understood in Transport Systems across
the country and around the world that
bus stop bypasses at the safest way to
segregate cyclists and road traffic in
many locations they can create safe
attractive cycling facilities alongside
bus stops and are included in the
department for transports National
guidance updated by the government in
research shows that segregated cycle
Lanes mean people who feel uncomfortable
cycling in traffic are much more likely
to make cycle Journeys this helps to
broaden the demographic of londoners who
cycle to include more women and children
and elderly and disabled people or
groups who are under absented among
London cyclists but who find their
benefits of cycling once they're
confident to try it tfl has really taken
steps to mitigate the risk of conflict
between cyclists and pedestrians
measures such as zebra Crossing points
and tactile paving help to ensure both
Buffy bus users and cyclists know what
is expected
undertakes an equality impact assessment
before introducing a scheme and uses the
same process to inform the life cycle of
a scheme I recognize some concerns have
been raised about Buster bypasses and I
want to see a street Network that is as
inclusive as possible for all ages and
abilities including for pedestrians and
those who may be more vulnerable
review will look into detail at the
equality implications of these
facilities and whether mitigations
should be required it will conduct video
surveys examine how customers use bus
stop bypasses and consider feedback from
pedestrian cycling and disabled people's
organizations this will include those
representing people with visual
impairments who we know have some
specific concerns to ensure their views
understood
I've also asked twofold to engage
through forums such as the glas deaf and
disabled persons organization Forum to
ensure a range of views are heard TF
will use the findings to consider how
the design of Buster bypasses could
evolve taken into account the
characteristics of specific locations
TFO will also look at any Behavior
change measures that may be needed to
ensure that everyone can use bus stop
bypasses with confidence the department
for transport and transport Scotland
have also funded their research project
looking at the inclusiveness of Buster
bypasses and continuous footways led by
living streets the report is expected
later this year and tearful also
considered this as part of their work
thank you
okay pause the clock or
all right um sorry I just like to thank
the members of nfb UK for coming out
today they've got a very busy day there
at the BBC and Parliament so um
unfortunately we don't have Nelly the
dog but we do have some members of the
organization so thank you for them for
joining us again Mr
um on the 15th of February on Eddie
nestor's radio show you said in response
to a request to meet with another uh
National Federation blind UK
um to have a meeting about Flo asking
for a meeting on floating bus stops you
said of course I'm happy to meet you
let's organize that on that very public
show they did Chase and Chase that
meeting and finally on 6th of April
received a letter uh from your Deputy
Mayor Seb dance saying the mayor cannot
accommodate a meeting with you would you
like to keep your word and review that
and make time to have a meeting with the
organization
I think the walking and cycling
commissioner will Norman and the deputy
mayor said dance have met with the
national Federation but their separate
groups are also meeting with the rnib
guide Dogs action and hearing loss
they're all on the side to you for blind
uh children and I think the the point
that seven war made the last time they
met the national Federation was once
there's more information the review that
may be a good time to have a further
meeting with this group but also other
groups as well that wasn't the question
and you may realize you aren't set dance
and you aren't will Norman so you're all
about London and they asked to have a
meeting with the mayor of London and the
mayor London said of course I'm happy to
meet with you let's organize that that
was who the meeting was with and you
later said to them finally on the 6th of
April the mayor cannot accommodate a
meeting I'm asking you would you like to
look at that again and will you make
time for them given that you so publicly
said that you would I'm more than happy
to be the national Federation and other
groups who I do regularly the point
about meeting the specialists in this
area is they can answer the questions
the group may have but I'm more than
happy to meet with the national
Federation in relation to any issues
they have it may make more sense to meet
with them once the reviews further down
the uh road but I'm more than happy to
meet with them at other groups thank you
Mr Smith so just confirm because you I I
don't want to get into a position where
I'm then reading this question out to
you sometime in uh later in the year and
you've again said actually I'm not going
to meet with them but you are definitely
going to meet with them this time if if
the group would prefer to meet with me
rather than the expert specialist
dealing with this that I'm more than
happy to uh meet with them just worth
saying that on the working group looking
into this review or a number of other
specialist groups as well so just to
reassure the national Federation there
are other groups also that are working
closely with thank you um and just
looking at that Collision data and I've
actually had this conversation with Will
Norman as well we know that a lot of
this won't come from Collision data
rights about near-misses it's about
people that aren't getting seriously
hurt and aren't reporting it that is
going to be the the number
um of uh that's going to be the number
of incidents and actually if you look at
the data the data is going to tell you
something quite shocking that every time
there's a collision it's really serious
and people get hurt because those are
the ones that are reported so what what
they've looked at say agreed to and I'm
hoping you'll say you'll agree is that
that monitoring should be through some
video footage of those sites and
observing and making and making creating
that data set from what is happening in
real time as opposed to looking at past
reports is that something that you'd
agreed to yeah I think one of the
concerns both pedestrians concerned
about cyclists particularly those
visually impaired have as well as
actually cyclists worried about lorries
and buses is the near misses as you
refer to so often if you're just hit on
the shoulder for example by cyclists you
may not report to but that's quite
distressing to you and so the video
surveys idea is one way to incorporate
the the incidents that aren't recorded
on the stats and it's this applies to
cyclists as well in relation to bus
collision and HUV collisions short of a
collision and injury there are many
cyclists I'm sure you've spoken to many
who also have incidents that are
recorded as collisions or serious
injuries but are quite serious so the
video surveys is one way to incorporate
The Pedestrian cyclist situation we're
also clearly looking at what we can do
to include experiences of cyclists in
relation to where they have been these
um floating bus stops thank you and I'll
just be really quick um on this last one
hopefully you can agree they said that
there has been talk as well of running
an enforcement campaign
um there's some really good enforcement
campaigns that work in partnership with
Charities at the moment but whereby you
see cyclists going on the pavement they
go and have a chat and see why that was
a bad thing to do and what what the
effects could be
um over summer as more people begin to
cycle and make make use of the sunshine
will you commit to there being an
enforcement campaign like that at
floating bus stops and bus bus stop
bypasses this summer one of the things
the reviews are looking into is the
issue of enforcement uh I think much of
the review will be finished by uh this
summer The the issue with the summer is
it's not that's not typical in relation
to people using buses Imagine Schools
closed for summer and so forth so that's
one of the reasons why with all the
video surveys
if you did it just over summer there
won't be reflective of what happens
during the course of the year my
enforcement is one of the issues that
the reviews are looking into and I can
come back to the assembly in relation to
the review when it's done later on this
year
thank you
thank you the next question
concerns fossil fuel-powered private
jets and it comes from assembly member
Polanski
we are in a climate emergency and people
are more aware of the need to consider
the flights they take and opt for low
carbon Alternatives if they can every
sector of the economy must cut its
emissions if climate catastrophe is to
be averted Aviation is no exception in
fact it's high-mitting sectors like this
that must be making the biggest changes
a recent study estimated that private
jets are five to four teams being upon 5
to 14 times more pollutant than
commercial planes per passenger and 50
times more pollutant than trains they
are also used by an incredibly small
number of people usually the most
privileged people in our society those
users are in a position to make choices
for or against our planet I was
surprised that the Prime Minister took
private jet trips costing the taxpayer
almost 500 000 pounds in just over a
week last year children out toxic
emissions last week I took a private
helicopter to Southampton and back to
visit a pharmacy a journey that would
have taken him an hour and 15 minutes
each way by train this is not the action
of a net zero leader the UK tops the
league table for private jet Journeys in
Europe with a flight taken off every six
minutes in 2022 these private jets are
The Preserve of the super rich and have
increased in numbers in recent years
this needs to be rapidly reduced if
we're serious about tackling climate
change frequent air Travelers should
consider firstly whether a particular
journey is needed at all and if so to
take the lowest carbon options wherever
possible in Europe high-speed train
connections exist on 70 to 80 of the top
10 most popular private jet routes well
I have no powers to regulate private
jets or travel more generally I can and
have object I can't and have objected to
expansion at London's airports as it
would increase the number of flights at
a time when we should be encouraging
people to take more sustainable
alternatives for private jet users
including the Prime Minister there are
always lower carbon Alternatives if he
feels those alternatives are not
acceptable he's in the fortunate
position to be able to find the
infrastructure needed to fund the
instruction needed to get people where
they want to go in a more sustainable
way
Thank You
London is Europe's private jet capital
and these are really bad both for air
pollution and for carbon emissions in
fact if someone flies to the south of
France and back on a return trip they
are emitting more carbon or can be
emitting more carbon than an average
Londoner an entire year now 17
000 private jets landed in the GLA area
I took off and landed in the jelly area
last year alone so that's not even
including Gatwick Stansted and Luton now
I've heard you condemn the Prime
Minister and I agree with that entirely
but would you condemn all private jet
use
just
just amplify your point of the most
popular routes in Europe the three most
popular flight from London one to Paris
one to nice one to uh Geneva you know I
accept there may be circumstances where
you know somebody somebody may need to
use a private chair but the point I said
in my substantive answer remains you
know there are alternatives available
including commercial flights and people
should consider the Alternatives
particularly when we know the carbon
footprint of private jets is so much
greater than uh commercial lines and
other Alternatives can I ask you for an
example of where someone should be using
a private jet a private jet to London to
Paris the All-Star is fantastic other
brands aren't available in afraid in
relation to trains
um but uh London to Paris is a good
example we're actually by the time
you've got to the airport they do tend
to be our salon by the way the standards
the stansters the lutons and so forth go
into Kings Frost jumping on the train
get into Paris is probably quicker as
well as less common footprint than
taking a private jet from London to
Paris so one percent of uh Aviation
sorry one percent of the people are
doing over 50 of the global Aviation
emissions so can I just absolutely
clarify you do condemn all private jet
use
no I think I just said okay they're
right I can I can I can appreciate there
may be exceptional circumstances what
would be an exceptional circumstance I
mean if we're condemning the Prime
Minister that's a fairly important job
and I agree with that what would be the
exceptional circumstance where someone
needs to take a private jet rather than
take Eurostar for example well there
could be exceptional circumstances
because of a time of day where the
person's got to get to a destination for
something that can't be met by the by
commercially so the time of day is more
important than the climate emergency
we'll give it hypotheticals for example
well no it's not hypothetical yesterday
for uh scientists said that we're going
to breach 1.5 degrees that's not
hypothetical so why should anyone be
using a private jet use when we're in a
climate emergency and we're rightly
asking people to change their traveling
habits in London should we not be asking
for super rich to change their habits
and not use private jets yeah I think I
think the question is am I in favor of
banning private jets and the answer is
no what I'm saying is there are
literally always Alternatives but I can
I can Envision a scenario where there
might have been alternative to a private
chair it should be exceptional
um but I'm not in favor as a dude you
are of closing airports down and banning
private jets and very clear that we need
to just transition around Aviation but
this isn't even about airports this is
about the wealthiest one percent now Mr
Mayor you do lots of measures around
tackling poverty and I support those
free School meals for instance excellent
but you very rarely talk about tackling
the wealthiest I'm a richest run a cost
of living crisis it should not be
difficult for a labor mayor to say I
condemn the use of all private jets why
won't you do that having quite clear
amounts I'm happy to read out again
relation to my views on the use of
private jets what I'm unwilling I think
you've been very clear that you're
standing for one percent Mr Mayor
what I'm very willing to do what I'm
very willing to do is to explain why I
think private jets shouldn't be used
where there's Alternatives and clearly
from the answer I gave there are lots of
alternatives to private jets uh I've
even got as far as to talk about the
difference between using a private jet
in relation to Cargo footprint and using
a commercial airline I'm not in the same
place as you are and I respect your
views which is to close all airports
down and ban private jets uh that is not
my view but I would ban private jets
within a second and I've heard you very
clear the answer is very clear
um for 99 of londoners will have heard
the mayor's answer very clear thank you
thank you the next question concerns the
cost of food crisis and it's in the name
of assembly member Ahmed
thank you Jeff
food price Rises have put huge pressure
on londoners budgets especially
low-income londoners who have to spend a
higher proportion of their income and
food in the last few months food banks
have seen falling donations Rising
energy costs and consistently high
demand while being affected by Price
Rises themselves
in response with limited resources and
Powers we're working to both help
londoners struggling to afford food
right now and support food aid providers
and local community organizations to
reduce the need for crisis provision
I've committed 130 million pounds in
emergency funding to ensure every
primary pupil in the capital receives
free School meals this could save
families around 440 pounds per child
ensuring parents aren't worrying about
how they're going to feed their children
it also guarantee every Primary School
child a healthy nutritious meal meaning
they don't go hungry in the classroom
and can better concentrate on their
studies hunger doesn't stop at the end
of the term which is why I've also
launched a free holiday meals program to
support families during the school
holidays over Easter more than 550 000
free holiday meals were given to Lincoln
families struggling with spiraling costs
in total partnership with the Felix
project and mayor's fund for London will
help provide 10 million meals over the
next year via community partner and
Community Partners including Charities
schools and Grassroots organizations at
the same time my food Roots program is
supporting resilient and sustainable
approaches to addressing food insecurity
our food Roots program has provided
short-term capacity grants for food
Partnerships in 30 London boroughs to
boost their work in the face of acute
capacity constraints caused by the cost
of living crisis the next phase of the
program will launch soon but households
should not need to depend on emergency
food provision to survive the drivers of
food insecurity must be addressed and in
London food insecurities overwhelmingly
caused by incomes being too low to
afford the basics I'm calling the
government to intervene by increasing
benefits while people are struggling and
removing the two child limit funding
Universal free school Mills and it's
using a Lifeline energy tariff for
vulnerable households
thank you very much Mr Mayor Mr Mayor
the resolution Foundation has said that
food prices are the new energy bills
when it comes to how people are
experienced the cost of living crisis
you will be aware of the shocking news
that the cost of infant formula baby
milk is now Sky High with parents having
to take Extreme Measures to feed their
babies including watering down Foods
substituting formula with condensed milk
and stealing baby milk from shops
experts say that the government needs to
make Staples such as fruit and
vegetables much cheaper and increase the
value of the Healthy Start vouchers
because we are on the brink of a Public
Health crisis given that londoners are
disproportionately affected in the
figures of poverty do you agree with the
experts Mr May
I I I I do but it's just worth reminding
colleagues that you know food prices got
up by more than 20 uh we're also
concerned about the issues around
obesity and often fresh fruit and
produce is more expensive uh than the
processed stuff that's less good for
families you can often get you know
chicken and chips for a pound your
family of three it's cheaper option
a little alternative so the point I'm
making is that yes of course I agree
with the the analysis you set up but
there are unintended consequences
by this food poverty we're seeing that's
why it's really important if we address
this we're we're also solving on other
issues if we don't the number of other
issues are exacerbated
thank you Mr Mayor Mr Mayor you have
talked about the emergency funding that
you will make available from September
for Universal free School meals could
you talk about any future plans to
extend that
so we're working with schools councils
and others to make sure that we're ready
to go
for the style of the next academic term
for free Universal Primary School meals
we've not waited in relation to the
holiday provision I mentioned in my
answer so I visited uh in
um Elin a big abundant house in Fulham
one of the community organizations who
were helping children during the
holidays have access to food there'll be
10 million meals provided over the
course of the next uh year at the same
time we are uh giving financial support
to law centers and advice centers often
people are eligible for benefits they're
not claiming for what they're eligible
for so make sure that families who are
eligible for benefits can do so at the
same time we're also funding uh warmer
home grants for those who whose bills
are huge because of lack of insulation
and uh so forth so eight million pounds
going towards supporting low income
families across our city 130 million
pounds going towards free school Mills
other Provisions being provided and
that's with the limited resources and
Powers uh we have the only person really
who can really solve this meaningfully
is uh the government but I'm afraid from
the prime minister's comments overnight
about him thinking that families have
now you know over over a responsible
income is is better than expectation it
shows how to touch he is
thank you very much Mr
thank you the next question concerns met
police performance and it comes from
assembly member pigeon thank you for
your question I asked for the
independent review to be conducted by
baroness Louise Casey because I was
deeply concerned about cultural issues
and systemic failings within the Met
Police Service
the evidence from that review is Diamond
baroness Casey found institutional
racism institutional misogyny and
institutional homophobia which I accept
she's described them at Police Service
as defensive resistant to change and
unwilling to engage with communities
Baron's Casey also concluded that Police
Service transparency and accountability
to londoners should be strengthened she
recommended that a new Causley board be
established to oversee the
transformation of the MPS while
maintaining the operational Independence
of the commissioner I've accepted all
baroness cases findings and
recommendations that were moving forward
with the establishment of the London
policing board building and baroness
cases recommendation that the board
should be similar to the model now used
for transport for London the London
policing board will be public facing and
I'll chair it personally it will convene
a range of experts reflective of
London's diverse population to provide
specialist advice to help deliver real
and sustainable improvements across the
MPS including wide-ranging cultural
reform the board will support the
mayor's office of policing and crime in
holding the Police Service to account as
part of our wireless strategic oversight
framework in line with mopac's statute
duties under the police Reform Act 2011.
officials are working at PACE to ensure
the London Police and board is up and
running as soon as possible this
includes working with tfl colleagues to
understand their experiences of the tfl
board and adopting best practice ideas
to ensure the successful operation of
the London policing board Baron's cases
Finance reveal serious failings in the
MPS that must be addressed with far
reign with far-region structural and
cultural forms of urgency I'm
unflinching in my resolve to support and
hold the MPS to account and the London
policing board will provide a form of
openness and transparency as we take
that work forward I won't be satisfied
until londoners have the Police Service
they deserve one that's trusted and
representative and which delivers the
highest possible service to every
community in our city as we work to
build a safety London for everyone
lovely thank you and we've talked before
you've placed a lot on the shoulders of
the new met commissioner being willing
to listen and to be open and yet just
last week we hear again from Her
Majesty's inspector that unsuitable
candidates are being recruited we also
heard about new files relating to the
Daniel Morgan case having been found in
a locked cupboard at Scotland Yard you
were only told about that around four
months after that Discovery so how are
you going to ensure that you have a grip
on everything that is going on in the
Met police
so the HMI report intervention was a
national report not just a Police
Service report and we've said for some
time uh that actually it's far too easy
to become a police officer far too
difficult to get rid of police officers
so me personally working with
parliamentarians in relation to the
legislation needed to change uh the law
in relation to a veteran it requires a
primary Act of Parliament and so we're
working with colleagues in Parliament to
get that going in the meantime we've not
waited so we've
City Hall have given more money to that
Police Service to improve the vetting
processes that includes for example the
anti-abuse corruption hotline that
includes for example more offices uh
supporting
um the the domestic abuse social
defenses unit and the hotline at the
same time to improve recruitment what
we've done from City holders investors
how are you going to get a grip on
everything that's going on like app to
accept you've got those work programs
but you know Morgan's stuff coming out
you were shocked by that you said that
how are you going to ensure that you
really have oversight of everything
that's going on let's use them as an
example just to give you an idea of a
scale or the challenge the new
commissioner and I have which is the
documents in relation to Morgan were
found in a filing cabinet locked away
and unless you're suggesting I go to
Every police station on property and
unlock cabinets we're going to be
realistic about that and we're going to
trust the commissioner and I do trust
the commissioner when the commissioner
says he's trying to get a grip on these
issues I think I think the policing
board is a good example of the public
facing work that's required but also
something that you've raised in the past
is outside expertise
um and the police and board will have
the outside expertise because I'll give
you an example cultural reform
question is the expertise inside uh met
Police Service or City Hall trying to
take a program of cultural reform answer
probably not and that's why you'd expect
somebody of the board to have that sort
of expertise and background there are
other examples I can give to you but
that's that's uh that's one of the
points that the same use case made about
how tfl is very different from the
Police Service management board and what
changes to policing in London do you
expect to see in a year's time I think
both the commissioner and I have said I
mean I've taken my lead from the
commissioner he thinks he'll take two
years to see him you said one year I'll
take two years to see the meaningful
change in relation to what we hope to
see but in the first six months you've
seen some of the progress
speeding up process around discipline
really important just in the first six
months being achieved more offices have
been removed from the Police Service in
the first six months they're only six
month period in recent uh past I think a
big change that I was I was referring to
but understandably you interrupted me
was relation to getting people from the
community to help the training of police
officers when they first come in because
often we're taking police candidates who
don't live in London and their
experiences of London is very different
and so that Community work is very
important at the Inception and then
going on to joining the police officer's
career I think what you're saying there
sounds some really positive steps but
this new board quarterly said it's going
to meet you're going to chair is at a
crucial Point Turning Point around the
Met police and rebuilding trust in
londoners and londoners need to see you
stepping up in this area I think being
more visible and we need to see those
visible measurable changes to protect
policing by consent so what metrics will
you put in place in order that we can
measure your performance as London's
police and crime commissioner a lot of
things that we did with the two football
went to go was to look at the
effectiveness of the board and one of
the things that the team at Mopac are
doing in speaking to tfl
is to learn from tfod's experience when
I took over about broad effectiveness
and so we bring into the policing board
some of those lessons we've learned so
one of the things we do for example with
tfl is get outside body to measure how
effective the TFO board has been both
the Ned's and the executive team and so
that's not being decided yet so we've
got to consult obviously that the new
memos of the board I don't want to
dictate to the board with the metrics
but that was your flavor of some of the
outside Market of homework I want to see
in relation to the police and board I
look forward to seeing that so we can
assess your performance in the new
board's performance thank you very much
thank you thanks
thank you before we move on to the next
question North beckton Primary School
are in the house and you're you're
welcome to come and see what we're doing
here
the next question to be asked is
concerning overcrowding and it comes
from assembly member moema that's how
lovely it is to be see people have my
size so you're most welcome
all londoners must have access to
suitable safe and decent housing it's
vital for health and well-being
I share the National Housing
federation's concern at the levels of
overcrowding in London according to the
ons London has the highest proportion of
households in England with fewer
bedrooms than required around eight
percent of London's households
overcrowded social entered housing is
the highest proportion of households in
other crowded conditions this problem is
caused by an undersupply of affordable
homes that meet the needs of londoners
this week I announced the city hall
funded a record-breaking number of
affordable homes last year and hit the
ambitious Target set by the government
for my affordable homes program
2016-2023 the government Target was for
us to start 116 000 Germany affordable
homes by April 2023 despite huge
challenges hard work of our partners and
my housing team has been that's exactly
what we've done this month I also
celebrated celebrated his now Target to
start building 20 000 Council homes in
London by 2024 a whole year early Deputy
Mayor Tom Copley and I went to see some
of these Newcastle homes in Brent where
we met a family of six who lived for 14
years in an overcrowded two-bedroom flat
they've now moved into a new home in a
street of brand new four bedroom houses
part funded by City Hall through work
like this we're delivering the homes
needed to ease overcrowding in London
I'm also ensuring that the market
delivers affordable homes through the
planning system record levels of
affordable housing were secured in
strategic schemes I approved in 2022 41
compared to 22 in 2016 and I'll continue
to help build the homes londoners need
through my 2023 to 2026 affordable homes
program the new program prioritizes
homes of social rent which is the most
affordable and most urgently needed type
of housing but it's vital that the
government increases the funding
available to me if we're going to
continue record-breaking levels of
building and create the homes londoners
desperately need loving requires 4.9
billion pounds annually to meet the need
compared to the 800 million pounds we
currently receive
thank you um Mr Mayor and can I also
um add to your congratulations to the
team and to Deputy Mayor Copley for the
amazing smashing of the target 116 000
homes and you know there were people
um in this chamber who said that it
wasn't possible to do and I'm really
glad that we've done it to quote Lisa
nandy there is no no way out of the
housing crisis without building more
homes
um but my question really on that um
obviously one of the issues that is a
consequence of not having adequate
numbers of Social and affordable housing
is the number of children living in um
overcrowded accommodation we saw through
covert the impact of that for on
people's mental well-being educational
attainment and um so on and I just
wondered what work it was possible for
um from City Hall perhaps in partnership
with others that could be done to help
alleviate some of those problems
yeah so really important point in your
race so just give an ideologies of uh
starts button register completions when
I first became only about 30 of homes
completed in our city were three bedroom
plus uh now it's north of 40 so we're
building more family homes as well which
is really important for the reasons you
uh assist and they're completed homes uh
by the way so the big challenges were
the consequences of overcrowding on
children mental health issues lack of
development educational attainment and
uh so forth I've got to be frank though
for the foreseeable future with somebody
I'm going to have the supply of homes to
meet the demand I gave you an example
the other day of a family Tom and I met
14 years in temporary accommodation
chronic overcrowding we met another
family 20 years in temporary
accommodation so the Legacy issues go
ongoing and plus people having families
still so that's one of the reasons why
we're lobbying for regulation of the
private rental sector so I'm really
pleased the announcement yesterday in
relation to the no-fault evictions that
deals the issue of security not about
cost and so it's still possible for a
landlord to improve increase the rents
which forces somebody to leave because
they can't afford the rent it's not no
full eviction and that's a big challenge
so the short to medium term we'll be
doing same as the lobby the government
for amendments in the rental Reform Bill
to include issues around rent freezes
and stabilizing the rents in London okay
and on that you know I completely agree
um what if we're looking at a maximum
amount of twenty three thousand twenty
three and a half thousand pounds
um in um Universal Credit to a household
that's not that doesn't even cover the
rent for a two-bedroom flat for one year
let alone the amount of space that a
family would need
um and so I know that you have made and
I um become a bit of a squeaky wheel
about the um the commission um which we
um which we need powers to evolve from
government to to put in place to work
with both tenants and landlords to set
in place as london-specific rent control
it'd be really good to see to hear how
um that would work in the context of the
announcement yesterday and if those if
that is something that you're also
asking government to do alongside those
amendments so what are things that we
know in Scotland that happened was in
Scotland the uh those campaigners
activists the layer party another
managed to say the Scottish government
to freeze rents uh last winter first for
six months
and they've now extended it to have a
cap of no higher than three percent
um so so you know it can work in this
country right
um Edinburgh Glasgow have seen big
increases that's really helped those
families and so we still seek to Lobby
the government uh the bill has a long
way to go before it's an act of
parliament uh you know with a good win
by the end of this year it's going to be
very tough and so we're carrying
lobbying the government and hopefully
it's an issue across Party Support in
relation to this issue by the way it's
not just another issue the the average
cost of renting outside London has now
gone above a thousand pounds for the
first time ever so I'm hoping we get
allies across the country
also agreeable to the idea of devolving
to different cities and regions but
what's relevant to London may not be
relevant to Burnley right and to devolve
into cities and regions the power to
look into the issue of uh you know rent
freezes and stabilizing rain controls
and working with landlords to get there
assembly member best
[Music]
like I feel like I'm at a press
conference or something uh thank you
chair
um just quickly Mr Mayor 18 of the
affordable housing starts last year were
family homes only 18 clearly that's not
going to meet the need to support
overcrowded homes will you look urgently
to make sure that that percentage
increases when we look at these stats
next year I don't recognize uh that
figure as I said in completions it's
north of 40 sorry it's I said 18 of
starts this year how big upon sorry big
pardon sorry sorry
um sorry I put in the microphone yeah
none
um so what we've done is as part of the
London plan we've given each local
Authority a requirement to make sure
they look at the need in their boroughs
and so we are working with Council to
increase the number of family-sized
homes for the reasons that have been
suggested by uh so remember Weimar and
so I'm happy to report back at a later
stage in relation to will be our
relation to progress uh made but it's
right that we need to have all sorts of
uh
of homes in London and that includes
family homes for the obvious reason the
only way a family can afford a home in
London that's the right sizes through
affordable housing because the average
cost of a terraced home to buy is now
850 000 pounds in London so this will be
the only route for a family to get out
of um overcrowded accommodation to one
that's got the right size
thank you we don't need any review we
don't need anything to tell you that 18
does not meet the need for family size
homes in London of affordable homes so I
just hope that next year when we look at
these stats that they are above 18 thank
you well in answer that question uh
chair the key thing is to make sure that
so fair enough fair enough uh the next
question is
um is is this now being asked by
assembly member Hall and it concerns the
Euless expansion update
thanks Joe I'm assuming this is a
question rather than a statement
tfl is on track to deliver the expansion
of Euless London wide on the 29th of
August
with air pollution contributing to
around 4 000 londoners dying prematurely
each year children growing up with
stunted lungs and a higher risk of
dementia in older people it's NOW
essential that the US is expanded
this is also a matter of social justice
London's poorest households are least
like to own a car in outer London 70 of
households earn less than ten thousand
pounds actually don't own a car
but poor households are more likely to
be affected by the impacts of toxic air
caused by traffic and congestion
londoners are already preparing for the
expansion and switching from older more
polluting Vehicles data shows that 9 out
of 10 cars seen driving and out of
London on an average day already meet
the US standards this is up from 85 in
November 2021 and 75 in June 2020. tfl's
check your vehicle tool where drivers
can find out if their vehicle meets you
less standards has been visited more
than 6 million times since November 2022
when I made the decision to expand the
eulos over 20 million pounds of my 110
million pounds scrappage scheme has
already been allocated to lower income
and disabled londoners and to London's
small businesses sold Traders and
Charities thousands of applications have
been approved so far helping drivers
across the capital transition to Greener
transport options TFA has undertaken an
extensive multi-channel marketing
campaign to raise awareness of the
expansion amongst londoners and home
counties drivers
activities running across traditional
media like TV radio and local and
national press it's also running at more
targeted locations like roadside posters
screens and Motorway service stations
petrol pump nozzles and on ways a
wayfinding app
tearful is also Distributing leaflets in
high footfall locations like shopping
centers and sending letters to the
owners of non-compliant vehicles via the
dvla this sits alongside engagement with
key stakeholders to raise further
awareness of the expansion and provide
any information that their communities
might require to prepare for the
expansion expanding the Euless
london-wide is a crucial part of
ensuring A Greener healthy and fairer
future for London the expansion of the
US on the 29th of August is a critical
element of London's fight against the
triple challenges of air pollution the
club emergency and congestion
thank you Mr Mayor the last mqt you said
nine out of ten of those households in
outer London who have a car are
compliant was that statement accurate
yeah the figure comes from analysis of
the data from existing anpr cameras and
is representative of circulating traffic
in the area the vehicles that will be
impacted by the expansion and those
figures from late last year's shows uh 9
out of 10 cars are nearly af10 van seen
driving in outer London on average they
are us compliant yeah okay so you've
corrected your terminology This Time by
using the term scene driving that is not
what you said last time so your
statement before when you did not
mention scene driving was inaccurate
wasn't it
I'm quite clear what the the data is uh
it's monitored through the automatic
number plate recognition data derived
from anonymized Daily Camera operations
are you incapable of saying yes I was
incorrect on my statement and I
apologize I should have said scene
driving because it gives the wrong
impression doesn't it I'm quite clear on
what the data says which is what I've
read out to we're quite clear and we're
quite clear that you were inaccurate
last time and I like to see that today
you have actually given the smmt proper
figures out has anybody asked you for
these figures before
ask me personally for these figures
before asked your office for information
on the smmt which for anybody watching
is a society of motor manufacturers and
Traders I'm not sure where chair
Murphy's probably gets lots of requests
all the time I'm sure they do I'm sure
you're selective on who you answer so
you don't want to correct the statement
then that you made last time I.E that
you were incorrect
no I'm quite clear what I've read I'm
happy to read out again if that helps no
it's it's a waste of time because you
won't accept the ever that you're wrong
in Harrow the figures we had before was
74 of vehicles vehicles are
non-compliant we see the figures that
have literally come out since we've all
been sitting here they're now at 83 and
my colleague
um assembly member Garrett will be
interested to see that uh Sutton is also
at 83 that represents 16
000 Vehicles these vehicles almost
certainly belong to hard-working
londoners who do not have as much money
as some they are going to be put in a
dire situation because of this do you
accept that
I accept there are some other notes
who've got non-compliant Vehicles which
is why we have the biggest ever
scrapping scheme our city or any part of
the country has seen 110 million pounds
available so far around 200 pounds has
been used and I'd encourage anyone who's
got an uncombined vehicle to first check
that it is non-compliant and then if
it's non-compliance see if they're
eligible for the uh scrappage scheme at
the same time we'll lobbying the
government for more support towards a
scrub consumers they've given to the
parts of the country we're hopeful the
government will give us more support
towards this property scheme to help the
sort of families
you come out with comments and and
statistics that we now have to wonder if
they're true because clearly this was
incorrect in two months ago when you
gave us the information of nine in ten
you poo poo it and say that it's hardly
anybody that's going to be affected in
Harrow 16 000 people will be affected in
Sutton 16 000 people will be affected
and all the boroughs around the amount
of information and and heart heart
rendering stories we're getting through
the post show this is going to have a
very detrimental effect on the poorest
in our societies hard-working londoners
do you not regret that at all
well as I said my original answer uh
Church the those in out of London who
suffer the worst consequences of air
quality it's those in London who suffer
the most deaths attributable to okay
yeah we've seen some of the benefits of
the US in Central and London which I
want them to people
you're repeating yourself so I'll go on
to a different point on this so what are
the ramifications of sorry and other
Home counties uh country County councils
refusing to allow any tfl Euless related
signage on their roads
what it means people live in the home
counties who may not have a vehicle
that's uh compliant won't be told that
the Eurozone is about to come on where
they're driving and so it means that
um those residents won't realize that
and may end up having to pay a fine
because they've not uh paid the 12
pounds 50. okay so what have you put in
place if July's judicial review
determines that the U.S should not
expand have you determined how you're
going to proceed
uh no you haven't we're still moving
ahead on the basis of the U.S Being
expanded at the end of August so if
they're saying that it's incorrect
you're going to ignore that and go ahead
anyway that wasn't a question you asked
the question you asked was no I'm saying
that now are you going to go ahead
regardless no no I always follow the law
and I'm quite clear relation to what we
think is going to happen in the digital
review your question was are we planning
for losing the case the answer is no but
if it's the case that the court finds
against us well consider that should it
happen so you haven't got any plans if
they do come out with that
no we're not expecting to to lose the
court case but surely you've got a plan
in place surely if if they do come out
with the fact that they don't think it
should go ahead what are you going to do
about it you can't not have a plan even
you Mr Mayor must have a plan surely
we do we do expect to uh have the U.S
expanded at the end of August three of
the five Grands of Jesus review were
rejected by the court two of the five uh
grounds have been said to be arguable uh
so proceeding to the full Heron we're
confident we will win the case we'll
have to wait and see what the Court
decides well that confidence might make
you look very stupid if they say you're
not to proceed and the fact that you
haven't got a plan if they don't do if
they say that I I find extraordinary
I'll leave it there thank you chair is
that a question or another statement
it was another statement thank you very
much assembly statement time
will tell what that was
um
assembly member Cooper uh thank you
chair
um Mr Mayor I do actually have a
question
um and I wondered if you saw the doctors
and the other health workers
um there was a lot of coverage they
decided to get on their bicycles to
emphasize
um the expansion and how necessary they
believe it to be we know that the Health
Service is under huge pressure partly
because of massive government
underfunding of the surface you
mentioned stunted lungs but I wondered
if you could just outline some of the
other health problems that will result
from not expanding the ulers and what
kind of pressures you think that would
then put the London NHS under no no
thanks for providing some balance to
this uh debate uh and it's just worth
reminding ourselves that these are tough
decisions
the decision to introduce the eulers
the introduced to expand the Euless the
decision to expand it again
but it's you know when you've met a
parent who's lost a child because of air
pollution or you meet a child who's
having difficulty breathing because of
stunted lungs how impacting you
uh what the evidence tells us and I use
the word evidence deliberately
said evidence right which is what some
people try and avoid is the evidence
tells us that breathing in nitrogen
dioxide nitrogen oxide particular matter
on a regular basis means children's
lungs are smaller forever forever once
they're stunted they can't grow back
and so that's an impact throughout the
course of their life
and these doctors
they gain Nothing by raising the rest of
this issue except fewer customers fewer
patients they're raising awareness of uh
this and by the way other experts
brackets provided evidence to close
brackets from Imperial College one of
the world's finest universities are
quite clear about the benefits of the
ultra low emission Zone and you know it
was a tough decision because I accept
there are some people who have got all
issues in relation to they're driving a
vehicle they need to run a vehicle and
it's unfortunately not compliant and
that's why we've introduced first 61
million pounds now 110 million pounds to
support these uh Farmers but you know
the worst thing of all when it comes to
politics is misinformation particularly
when it comes to issues it's important
as
issues is important as children's uh
well-being and you know people in the
gallery including those children are
watching I'm being heckled talking about
air quality and air pollution I
apologize for the
for the behavior of the family member
some members it's not your time to speak
thank you very much chair thank you Mr
Mayor for that
and now it is assembly member Garrett
thank you chair so just to clarify Mr
Mayor do you accept that on the latest
figures out today 16 of vehicles in
outer London are not ulos compliant now
firstly congratulations on the coup on
being the new leader of the uh these
sort of comments Mr Mayor are the reason
why your friends and colleagues and
people who work with you have such a
warm opinion of you and your nature if
you could answer my question though and
write the mixed statements I would
appreciate that so do you accept that 16
of vehicles in outer London are
non-compliant well I'm sorry that the
moment doesn't accept my congratulations
um
there you go
um no I I don't accept uh the figure
that referred to by uh the uh leader of
the conservative uh group I'm quite
clear in relation to tfl's always been
consistent since 2017 in using figures
from the automatic number plate
recognition cameras and from 26 sept
from 2017 we've been comparing apples
with apples rather than Vehicles
registered for a number of reasons
Vehicles registered isn't an accurate
reflection of uh information often cars
are registered in one place but maybe
driven elsewhere uh often a car may not
be used as well as people think it's
going to be used often there are other
exemptions available
for example we've introduced schemes to
do with exemptions and disability
exemptions so the most accurate data is
the automatic number plate recognition
data and that shows in outer London uh
more than 9 out of 10 vehicles are
compliant and that's gone up from what
it was appreciation okay you don't
accept that figure that's fair enough
that is at least clear
um so you present you layers you've
spoken at length this morning just now
about why it's a positive change why is
it do you think that so many of your own
party colleagues aren't persuaded about
the need to bring it in in August well
so in London we've got uh I think 49 uh
labor MPS I think 47 are public is
setting are saying positive about this
uh in London we have 21 labor councils I
think all of them have been supportive
of Uris we have a number of them as the
assembly here who are labor I think all
of them are supportive of uh you know I
mean and that should be fair there are
some conservatives
very supportive of you as the chair of
the climate change committee sure but
look there's a digital Flagship policy
though and you present the care when I'm
interrupting because you're now changing
the subject and not answering my
question but you have now answered so
you've accepted that I mean this is your
Flagship policy and you present it as
you have done this morning that you know
why would anyone be against it and yet
some people in your own party are
against it Rachel Reeves who's hoping to
be Chancellor of the exchequer
um she was asked four times on LBC two
weeks ago if she supported it and she
sort of treated it like a bad smell that
she tried to waft away why is it you
think that she didn't enthusiastically
endorse and support your Flagship policy
what can I suggest you I far more
support in my party than he does amongst
his group of assembly members and my
party is far more united than his party
uh is and so I'm quite comfortable with
the support I've received from so why
did you four times refuse to support
your Flagship policy Mr Mayor I'm quite
comfortable and grateful for the support
I've received from my party nationally
at regely and from those on the assembly
I mean is it that you think that Rachel
Reeves doesn't care about children's
stunted lungs why did she four times
refuse to endorse your policy well I
mean she could have enthusiastically
backed it you're getting proud of it why
do you think she didn't do that well I
think I think I think I've been quite
clear uh chair that I'm really pleased
for the support I've received from not
just uh those colleagues here but from
the national airport I think most
recently this week
uh castama was on
one of the radio stations and was
incredibly supportive of this uh policy
so I'm I'm quite clear we've got support
from not just the doctors referred to by
a previous question uh not just uh just
forgive me I sense that you are
monologuing
said I'm very concerned about the
economic impact the current rollout
plans will have on residents and small
businesses you were earlier on this
morning in response to a different
question extremely eloquent about your
concern about food poverty what impact
do you think your Euless expansion will
have on food poverty but I I agree with
SEMA in relation to the concerns that we
both have in relation to the impact on
small businesses which is why we've set
up the scrubbish game of 110 million
pounds and in fact uh you know seem as
very supportive of our policy what she
wants to do and I agree with her is to
get the government to give more support
to small businesses Charities Logan
families and uh so forth I'm also quite
clear the same families who suffer from
food poverty have children some of whom
with stunted lungs children with asthma
but also their parents when they're
walking their kids to school are
breathing in the poison from these uh
Vehicles those children with food
poverty uh whose families earn less than
ten thousand pounds uh seven out of ten
of those families in outer London don't
own a car
so three out of ten do and what impact
do you think your Euless policy will
have on food poverty I think what we'll
do combined with uh the free School
meals in September lead to children
being able to breathe cleaner air leads
to their parents having to take less
time off work because of a respiratory
conditions so if they're on Zero's
contract earning more money but the free
School meals from September which which
okay
that's a different policy Mr Matt so it
seems to me you have no sympathy at all
for anyone who's pushed further into
poverty or into poverty by your 12 pound
50 a day cost of living charge I hear no
sympathy for those people from you I've
been quite clear in relation to the
policies we've announced to support
those families who may have a
non-compliant vehicle at the 170 pounds
supports those lower income families
supports Charities supports small
Traders and supports sole Traders as
well clear if you had more money from
the government we could provide even
more assistance to those families
okay I didn't hear a single word of
sympathy there sure so I will leave it
there
assembly member Prince
Keith
is that anything
thank you
Mr Mayor you're not correct are you when
you said in answer to the question on
signage that if you can't put signs in
the county roads that people will just
have to incur the charge without notice
I'm sure you are aware that there is
legislation that requires you to put
signage uh in advance so that somebody
can choose an alternative route and that
is why indeed in some of the boroughs in
London the whole Borough will not
actually be within the Euler Zone and
some of the roads will be excluded from
the Euless Road in order to allow that
Escape Route
so I think we're sort of cross-published
I think the question was in relation to
the consequences of the home counties
not putting up signs and my performance
of Home counties don't put up signs but
residence drivers won't know that
they're entering into London which is uh
go to london-wide ultra low emissions
but they they will because the sign the
signage will be
before you enter the Euless Zone with an
Escape Route so it just means that as
I've already explained people will go
into parts of London there will be
certain roads in London that they can
enter Because that's the only Escape
Route out of the Euless you can't just
all of a sudden be inside the Euless and
start paying it there has to be an
Escape Route that's in the legislation
so there are signs within London and
there'll be science on the borders of
London but the other there being signs
in and around Tom counties is to make
people well away in advance of them
reaching London rather than get into the
border and then having to do a detour so
we're hoping the home counters change
their minds as indeed London councils
have changed their minds
because there's nobody's interest to try
and use this as a back Doorway to
frustrate the ultra Mission Zone oh I'm
going to leave it there actually thank
you Mr
thank you can I welcome to
I do apologize assembly member Davao
Mr Mayor in terms of all these issues
can you just quickly update us where the
government is you mentioned it briefly
but didn't tell us where we are about
adding some more money into the scrap
each scheme because of course the
members opposite have been campaigning
for that haven't they I bet they're not
but that's it's
please see if they're going to ask any
questions around that so where have we
got to with government or on adding more
money to the scrappy scheme like they've
given the rest of the UK rather than to
London well if we work in a basis that
when members in this assembly raise
issues about con of concern about
poverty in those in outer London and
concerns about those in home counties
you'd expected them to be lobbying the
government
for more support towards for example a
scrappy scheme and we were hoping
there'd be a cross-party working to try
and persuade the government to give
London and the home counties the same
support they've given other parts of the
country those in Manchester those in
Birmingham those in bath those Imports
but then elsewhere the good news is we
have seen colleagues in the home
counties from other parties labor and
other parties lobbying the government
for more support the MP for Slough and
others I've seen evidence of colleagues
in this assembly uh lobbying the
government for more uh support so if
they are sincere and we've got to work
in the basis they are sincere about
expressing concerns about constituents
who may be affected by this the words
used by the new leader of the
conservative group is those suffering
food poverty you'd expected them to be
lobbying privately and publicly the
government I've seen evidence of that
we're going to carry and Lobby in the
government probably and publicly for
more support towards it because we do
care about those families I mean is that
very government that still says
something about you Les in one place
amongst their services when they're
talking amongst themselves but actually
in government says actually we want to
support you Les throughout the country
and we're willing to put money behind it
sadly not in London is that correct yeah
we've seen evidence of them playing off
other parts of the country against each
other so some parts of the country
they're saying you've got to do a Clean
Air Zone you less otherwise you'll be in
breach of air quality laws and we've
done that and our head of the game and
making progress seen as a world leader
and no support from the uh government
and so it's a good example of the
government saying one thing to one part
of the country another thing to another
I am confused by the the opposition
stance within the assembly because I'm
not sure whether they support you Les or
they just don't support it now because
the cost of living crisis they talk a
lot about the cost of living crisis
around that but they don't really want
to add the other issues in isn't it
isn't it a bit unfair that it's always
you adding to the cost of living crisis
but actually we ignore completely we
ignore completely all the other issues
of their policies that add to the cost
of living crisis well I'll tell you what
let's do an audit let's put the money
where it is what their what their
policies do in terms of the burden on
cost living crisis when actually this
cost is about making sure cleaner air
quality that even even the evening
standard that's one of your biggest
critics has got Beyond you on has got
behind you and supporting you on it
because that's the trend and they may
laugh but actually it's not a laughing
matter when you're talking about the
health of love when you're talking about
early deaths and you can be Cavalier and
you can play your political points but
in terms of what we need to be doing and
moving ahead on this issue we will
already behind because of Boris Johnson
delayed the issues of You Les we're
catching up and in that delay people
have suffered now if you're prepared to
let that suffering goes on Mr Mayor so
let's do it what's the plan B if you if
you're found in terms of legal she's
going to make yourself legal compliant
but there's nothing in terms of legal
actions that's going to stop you lesbian
introduced the the thing is uh uh that
when when the members of the assembly
laughed I reference the standard you'd
have forgotten that George Osborne is no
longer the editor of the Saturday which
is why they're so upset and the good
news is the standards have got excellent
journalists some of them sitting in the
uh Gallery today and you know do
excellent work reporting on as relevant
to uh uh londoners and we're very
grateful the excellent work they uh do
but here's the point where where'd you
have this group complaining about the 7
000 plus pounds added to the owner
occupier because of mortgage is just
going up because of their policies what
is their concern about the 20 increase
in food inflation sort of armored raised
because of a direct consequence of uh
their policies what is their concerns in
relation to exports going down because
of the hard brexit causing real problems
to these uh families but you know the
the the point that that Leonard Cooper
was mentioned in relation to the doctors
is you've got medics
you've got Health experts you've got
parents of children with stunted lungs
saying they would like this policy
rolled out
I understand there are concerns with
some people who've got vehicles that are
polluting and so why are they working
with us to Lobby the government for more
financial uh support and that's what
that's what I understand that's why I
can understand people being suspicious
that their motives aren't concerned
about these families I'm concerned about
us going too fast it's a good example of
them always being opposed to this policy
2017 2019 2021 and 2023
thank you
thank you can I welcome to the public
Gallery the lewisham peoples Parliament
thank you you're very welcome here
our next question
concerns cannabis smoke and it's from
assembly member devanish
thank you
the use of illegal drugs harms
individuals families and communities
across our city Dame Carol Black's
review estimated the illegal drugs
Market to be worth 9.4 billion pounds a
year in England Wells but that the
associated Health harms crime and
impacts on my Society could be costing
us more than double that
there's no question that we need to do
more to tackle this epidemic the police
have an important role and the
commission and I are committed to
strengthening the Met Police Services
response to the organized criminals
behind the drugs trade drug-related
violence and neighborhood crime and add
social behavior local policing is
particularly important in this regard
and the commission has updated
turnaround plan will aim to provide the
strongest ever neighborhood policing but
policing alone cannot solve a complex
social problem like the misuse of drugs
project Adder has led to a significant
number of police seizure of drugs
weapons and illicit finances coupled
with local Authority and voluntary
sector work to support vulnerable drug
users into treatment they learn drugs
forum has brought these Partners
together along with others from the
health and criminal justice system to
ensure there is a holistic approach to
tackling drug-related harms and crimes
I'm pleased to say that through City
Hall funding and the partnership built
through London drugs forum project Adder
is being expanded to carry its vital
work across the whole of London
drug laws themselves remain an issue of
significant debate it's right that the
mayor of London should make a
constructive and evidence-based
contribution to that debate that's why
I've convened experts from medicine law
policing Academia and community
relations to form the London Drugs
commission the commission is considering
the impact and effect of current
cannabis laws and crime particularly
violent crime public health and economic
outcomes that is exploring police
enforcement of those laws and support
and treatment services for addicts
commission is also examining the latest
evidence from the UK and across the
globe on the harms of cannabis the best
methods of prevention the most effective
criminal justice response is the public
health benefits of different approaches
and other relevant factors The Institute
for Global City policing base at
University College London has been
appointed as a research partner to
gather and review this evidence based on
This research the commission will make
recommendations to improve the current
legal framework and practice I won't
know what they'll recommend until that
work's been completed but I look forward
to receiving their findings in due
course
thank you Mr Mayor let me read the
question I actually asked you as you
didn't bother to answer it from the
Member of Parliament for Holborn and
Saint Pancras quote there's a family in
my constituency every night cannabis
smoke Creeps in from the streets outside
into their children's bedroom aged four
and six kierstama said that's not
low-level crime it's ruining lives I
actually agree with him for once do you
agree with him I do but you didn't read
the next paragraph what he said so we
won't put any punches in this everyone
protected everyone respected that's what
Justice Means and the Tories are soft at
it soft and antisocial Behavior soften
the crime that most affects working
class communities only labor will
protect them I agree with that too well
the person responsible for crime in
London for the last seven years believe
it or not I think is you and uh cannabis
uses become far more widespread in fact
it's effectively become criminalized
under your Reign isn't that correct well
actually the areas in the country where
they've started drug diversion methods
are in areas like Thames Valley last
time I checked there wasn't a labor
police and crime commissioner uh there
Durham uh as well so if he suggested his
colleagues in Durham and Thames Valley
are somehow in vertical as a soft I
think he'd shake that up with them I'm
quite clear I'm quite clear we've got a
evidence-based commission taking place
you've got people that I respect like
William Hague supportive of this
approach the chair of the assembly also
supportive of this approach and I'm
disappointed he's playing Party politics
with an issue about evidence-based
policy but again they did the same with
Euless so I'm not surprised well what
you wanted to talk about doctors earlier
so I'll read you a paper from the Lancet
the medical journal entitled cannabis
use and public health time for a
comprehensive harm to others framework
and in there as you seem to be still
very keen to decree analyze drugs it
says and I quote the principal adverse
consequences that can occur in
association with cannabis use include
acute psychometric control impairment
cannabis use disorder eye dependence
mental health problems EG psychosis
depression suicide driving impairment of
fatal or non-fatal injuries from motor
crash I can go on and on isn't it true
Mr Mayor that you want to decriminalize
drugs that will really harm londoners
and just to remind you this is the
London assembly this is the greater
London Authority we shouldn't be talking
about Durham and Thames Valley which
will be talking to you about your
polling record for seven years in crime
in London and kirstarma as weak as you
on these issues but he's trying to
pretend that he's tough on crime but we
all know that you're soft on crime Mr
Sadiq Khan
you know what I mean I mean
yes um I I have some Toleration for
members making statements people from
every side do but it's shouldn't be like
looking for a needle in a haystack for a
question
I'll leave it there Mr Mr chairman as
he's clearly not he's clearly not going
to answer any of my questions as usual
I I think that that question has has
left the room thank you
um
the next the next question is in the
name of assembly member McCartney
and it concerns London's businesses
thank you Jim
yes in also the question the governance
incompetent management of our economy
and their brexit deal have Unleashed
inflation and of course to live in
crisis that's making the cost of doing
business in London harder than ever
and London is the engine of the UK
economy and when the capital succeeds so
is the rest of the country but sadly
National policies are holding us back
I've been clear that the government
should be working with us to help unlock
growth and prosperity and get our
economy far in all cylinders the
countries facing an economic downturn
the UK is predicted to face the worst
recession and the weakest recovery in
the G7
the government's failure to deliver the
funding and investment our Capital needs
is limiting our ability to tackle these
challenges head on and return to growth
and prosperity I've been engaged with
businesses and Industry bodies to better
understand the support needed that's why
I've been disappointed that the
government won't yet reinstate tax-free
shopping for overseas visitors that
would give a much needed boost to
London's retail and Hospitality sectors
another inescapable truth is that the
government's extreme Hardline version of
brexit is having a detrimental effect on
londoners and our businesses impacting
growth trade and talent at a time we can
least afford it I've called for a more
constructive relationship with the EU
and a pragmatic debate about the
benefits of being a part of the Customs
Union and the single market for example
the government should use post-brexit
restrictions preventing young Europeans
coming to the UK which should provide a
boost to our economy in London with two
thirds of businesses in our city
struggling to fill the vacancies they
need I've also called on the government
to allow us to create a regional
shortage occupation list that's one way
to give businesses the ability to track
and retain talent in the areas they need
the most the government should also
reform the planning system the center
for City's recent report found Rising
costs of workspaces and housing have had
a negative impact on London's
productivity and competitiveness
thank you Mr Mayor a recent figures show
that UK exports are now the lowest in
the G7 do we have any figures as to how
that's affecting London and our exports
I'm afraid the figures aren't broken
down by regions and by uh at London but
we're a big Expos of services and we do
know there's been an impact in relation
to UK Services being exported because of
a lack of financial passport and with
the European uh Union so no figures for
London but you've seen the last two days
car manufacturers have now expressed
their concerns in relation to the
consequences of them still staying in
the UK to let an impact on exports
thank you you mentioned towards the end
of your opening there that you've
recently called for a review of
post-brexit visa rules now small
businesses in my constituents in Enfield
and haringey particularly for example
the restaurant sector along green lanes
are really struggling not only with
inflation and other costs but also with
recruitment staff and what exactly is it
that you want the government to do about
visa rules and are they listening are
you actually having active discussions
with them so the challenge we have in
London is not simply a skill shortage
but a labor shortage
and so I'm speaking to restaurants not
just in your situency but across the
city now who sometimes aren't open at
lunchtime because they're kind of Two
Cities because they look at the staff
and it's a big big problem I I accept
we've got to be training at more people
uh from London and elsewhere in our
country to do these jobs but some of
these jobs
um are still not going to be filled
we've got record numbers of vacancies in
Hospitality social Care Health Care and
so forth so even the best in the world
if every single person you know who
could be trained was trained we still
have vacancies in these uh sectors
sometimes the government is if they
introduced in the short term
either a covered recovery Visa
or it was to devolve to other parts of
the country including London a regional
shortage occupation list we could speak
to employers say what is the shortages
and allow people to come to the UK to
fill those shortages and by the way if
they come to the UK and they're doing
this work they're paying taxes they're
paying less insurance the business is
doing better they're paying taxes
they're paying corporation tax vat and
so forth so it's a virtual Circle the
shops benefit more people shopping and
so forth and so there is no downside to
this and the only reason the government
is saying no is dogma and you know
businesses are closing down because of
government Dogma
okay thank you thank you Mr Mayor
thank you I'm
sorry oh assembly member Fortune I do
apologize
I gave it a wiggle I gave it a wiggle
um this is a really important question
when business is working in London it's
going to benefit all of us
do you remember Mr Mill we had a
conversation a while back about uh small
businesses in London uh we were talking
about the Federation of small business
and the fair play uh Fair pay reports do
you remember that conversation we had
and that that Focus was about prompt
payments and that was in September 2021
and I asked if payments from the GLA
were prompted on time and so I went back
to look on the notes of this because you
said at the time that you recognize the
issue you checked that we pay our
suppliers quickly and speedily
particularly the the small ones
um the difficulty we had was that that
wasn't actually happening at the time
just to remind you in 2018-19 there were
1280 invoices paid late so that's 13.5
million pounds of money that should have
gone from the GLA out to small
businesses that was that was late and in
1920 the 1242 invoices that's 12.4
million pounds delayed at the GLA that
was going out late to to small
businesses I asked the 2021 figures and
understandably you didn't have them and
fair enough you said you'd you'd send
them to me and I was quite reassured by
some of the things you said because and
you know like I went back to look at the
notes and you recognized how important
it is and this is you particularly with
small business where cash flow is so
important if they if they don't get that
prompt payments like I said that was
back in September 21.
unfortunately
June 2022 so September October November
December January February March April
May June 10 months later I had to ask
you again because I didn't get those
those figures which was which was
disappointing I finally got them in July
now those figures in July told me that
sadly only only 84 of those those
payments were on time which means as a
result of that 9.7 million pounds was
was held here at the at the GLA that
didn't go out to to businesses now
no one else is to blame here we can't we
can't shift this off you're the mayor
you're the chief exec this is your firm
and you're paying late
um
do you have I asked you if you had a
clear policy on making sure the payments
were prompt and you said to me yes we do
have a policy and you said I know
because I checked it a while ago and
it's always worth being vigilant so just
to remind us all what's what's the
policy in terms of percentage of
payments that you want made promptly
so I'm not going to figure with me but
there is there is a there is a target
debate on on within X days uh that's not
good enough in relation to 84 should be
higher than that I can come back to him
uh within the next 24 hours as to what
the figure is I'll be unsurprised to
find out how good oh great so so it's
the payments it's got to be 90 that's
the Target and that's not a new Target
and again you said here it's a really
important issue and it will be
heartbreaking heartbreaking if now that
we've come out the pandemic business did
not stay afloat because of lack of cash
flow
so 90 is the Target so I went to have a
look at performance across across the
period so 13 14 and I appreciate that
this wasn't your melty this was the
previous mayor it was
92.5 that's Target hit 14 15 it was 92.7
93 Target hit 15 16 it was 93.8 percent
Target hit
2016 2017
oh
that's the year you were elected it's
dropped down to 88.5 that's the first
time it's dipped below the target target
missed 1718
81 81.9 was Target missed
1920 that we talked about there was
there was a bit of a peak there it went
up to 84 and then we get to 2021 which
was that figure I was looking for in
July as I said that was 9.7 million
pounds held up uh which should have been
payments from here going to to small
business which as you said is is
heartbreaking
last couple of years aren't great either
so this is after I asked you the
question this is after you promised me
you're going to look at it this is after
you said you grip it uh 2021 2022 has
gone down to 79
cash figure on that is 16.5 million
pounds held here in the GLA
your firm that's not going out to to
small businesses it's delaying payments
it's breaking that cash flow at a really
difficult time
2022 2023 latest figures I would reckon
you're gonna go hide you'll go lower
where do you think it's gonna go
74 percent
74 so over a quarter of payments
from your firm
going out to small businesses for the
late
so bear in mind I asked this question in
September 2021 I asked it again in June
2022 here we are in 2023 you've promised
to grip this you've promised to take
control of it
why are things getting worse
it's simply not good enough it's simply
not good enough uh even if you excuse
the coverage years what your stats
showing so it's poor before the covered
years and it's poor after the coverage
years so that's not good enough reason
um and you're right but the reason for
the Heartbreak is because the the cash
flow coming in is different in paying
your bills and not paying your bills
and so
um to all those firms who have received
payments later than they should have
done I apologize
uh you know as soon as best question
comes over I want to go and look into
this personally
I'm happy to work with you in relation
to seeing what the issue is I can't
think of an excuse to go as low as 74 we
could quibble about if you said to me is
89 80 I could we could talk about that's
not good enough and the target's not 100
by the way the target is 90 for a very
good reason because it's not realistic
100 Target
um that's got to be sorted out so I I
appreciate that and actually I
appreciate the apology but you will
understand the touch of cynicism here
that I asked the question
no that's fair that's fairly 23. I think
it's very still going so what
reassurance can you give me and London
businesses that you're gonna grip this
well because we don't want platitudes
you know it's kind of sort of you know
kind of City checks in the poster can't
don't worry about it leave it with me
gov I'm on it how are you going to grip
this firstly
can I just thank you for the way you've
raised it and going through it as you've
done
I promise you made an impression on me
today in relation to promises I made to
you which is a serious propensity
seriously to remember the assembly not
be in action
um and can I agree to speak to you next
week in relation to you me reassuring
you privately you're happy with what
I've found and what I want to do and
we'll take it from there because you
know politics aside both on the same
ends it's still not happening so if
that's agree with you I can agree to
meet with Peter next week and see what
hopefully I don't know about that next
what the issue is and then I saw this
out because what we both wanted they've
done the work right I get the money they
deserve thanks and you'll understand
that like Arnie I'll be back
well done a number of assembly members
have got mayoral commitments today so
that's that's really good uh I think
we'll now take a break for five minutes
if that's okay
10 minutes who's what's the consensus
without a vote look at me tell me 10
minutes or five
ten ten ten minutes from now thank you
foreign
of the greater London Authority please
stand by
this is the broadcast from City Hall the
home of the greater London Authority
please stand by
this is the broadcast from City Hall the
home of the greater London Authority
please stand by
this is the broadcast from City Hall the
home of the greater London Authority
please stand by
this is the broadcast from City Hall the
home of the greater London Authority
please stand by
this is the broadcast from City Hall the
home of the greater London Authority
please stand by
this is the broadcast from City Hall the
home of the greater London Authority
please stand by
this is the broadcast from City Hall the
home of the greater London Authority
please stand by
this is the broadcast from City Hall the
home of the greater London Authority
please stand by
this is the broadcast from City Hall the
home of the greater London Authority
please stand by
this is the broadcast from City Hall the
home of the greater London Authority
please stand by
this is the broadcast from City Hall the
home of the greater London Authority
please stand by
this is the broadcast from City Hall the
home of the greater London Authority
please stand by
this is the broadcast from City Hall the
home of the greater London Authority
please stand by
this is the broadcast from City Hall the
home of the greater London Authority
please stand by
this is the broadcast from City Hall the
home of the greater London Authority
please stand by
this is the broadcast from City Hall the
home of the greater London Authority
please stand by
this is the broadcast from City Hall the
home of the greater London Authority
please stand by
this is the broadcast from City Hall the
home of the greater London Authority
please stand by
this is the broadcast from City Hall the
home of the greater London Authority
please stand by
this is the broadcast from City Hall the
home of the greater London Authority
please stand by
convene if possible
thank you
thank you members for the next question
I'm going to hand over the chairing to
the deputy chair Dr sahota
thank you Chad thank you walking is an
important way to keep healthy and enjoy
the world around us and for those who
are who are able it's often the best way
to get out into London's array of green
spaces to connect with nature it's
important we protect both public
footways and connected Wildlife wherever
possible my transport strategy includes
their key proposal to protect improve
and promote the walk along the network
and tearful provides a range of guides
and that advice on how to get the most
from London's walking routes foot path
is located within the boundary of land
owned by bark and Riverside limited it's
run east to west along the River Thames
and North up to the gorse brook and it's
designated embarken and dagenham as a
public right-of-way Park and Riverside
limited is the master developer
responsible for the Barkan Riverside
development Barker Riverside limited is
a joint venture private limited company
between lnq new homes and the greater
London land and property limited g-lab
my Deputy for housing and residential
development Tom Copley sits on the
Barking Riverside limited board along
with two jelly officers I visit the site
many times during my time as mayor and
have seen the Riverside ecology it's an
asset to the area and those who access
it with a rich and diverse variety of
wildlife spanning across the site I
understand that bark and Riverside
limited is fully committed to protecting
and enhancing the wildlife habitat areas
along a footpath and across the site and
has agreed to planning obligation to
support this as part of that barking
Riverside limited is committed to
ensuring the footpath is preserved for
public use I'm aware though that works
will be required to the Riverside to
enhanced flood protection as new homes
are developed closer to the River Thames
in line with the Thames Estuary
2100 plan
for path 47 Falls within the boundary of
these works and due to the nature of the
engineering activity the footpath will
need to be temporarily diverted as homes
are developed in and around the
Riverside barking Riverside limited will
be required to work with residents and
the irrelevant statutory bodies to
ensure suitable notification ahead of
any temporary diversions and manage the
ecological impacts accordingly I'm
advised these works are part of the
overall plan to the to Enhance Landscape
habitats and accessibility consistent
with my London plan and The Wider vision
for River Thames
thank you for that answer I'm it's new
information to me that there is going to
be another temporary dime version
because there was one in 2014
Could you
um undertake Mr Mayor to to get barking
Riverside limited to Embark upon some
public information because certainly
people in The Barking Riverside area
including Thames View and The Wider uh
barking and dagenham as well our viewing
with concern the pace of the the pace
that the development is rushing towards
the Thames and I think they need
reassurance in the area of what the
future plans will be and a lot of
information up front not just waiting
until the last minute to tell people
that the footpath is going to be
diverted could you give that undertaking
I I I can and can I go a step further so
so I raises with Tom Copley yesterday
for reasons you'd appreciate and I think
the reason why your point is is more
important is because that work with the
community before the plans are finalized
is what you want to do to get the
confidence back so I was told that that
brl are intending to divert the footpath
in stages to minimize uh the extent of
the diversions and would engage with the
community in advance of that stage I
think your advice is do it now no no yes
so let me take that away and and I'll
ask Tom to just confirm that with you so
you're reassured and you can pass that
into local community because otherwise
it doesn't engender confidence building
does it I mean in terms of the free
advert space that I've got here anybody
who wants to go and who
um enjoy the enjoy football 47 and the
wildlife that collects around it you can
just go to barking Riverside Station or
barking Riverside Pier to enjoy it
finally Mr Mayor we've talked about the
value of of green space and you so
passionately spoke of that earlier do
you support your party Leader's plan to
build on London's Green Belt I think
what I think to to clarify what the
leader of their party was saying was
there are some pieces of green bell that
clearly on Greenbelt think of cardboard
shoes that are green belt but aren't
really green belt and I think what he's
referring to is situation where there
are some pieces of land that are
designated Green Belt but clearly on and
on those pieces of land if they are
developable and won't damage the the
green space than those should be
considered but it should be a decision
made by the local Authority consultant
and working with local residents
Mr Smith how quickly do you think the
green belt would look derelict if that
was the only uh criteria for building on
it
how so how how quickly do you think that
the green belt would become derelict if
that was the criteria for justifying
developing on it car washes
if you use that precedent you know so
very little of the Greenbelt around
London is used by car washes I've been
quite clear you know Green belts are the
lungs of our city they're there to
prevent Urban Sport and all the rest of
that stuff but also they could
indirectly by giving permission of
Greenbelt can inflate the land price and
stuff so there are really good reasons
why we've got the protection thank you
very much
the next question is
um concerning women and girls in London
and it's in the name of assembly member
Hall thank you chair thanks for the
question I'm a proud feminist and I'm
committed to doing everything I can to
tackle gender inequality across London
for international women's day in this
March I invited experts to a policy
Summit to discuss key issues affection
women and girls I also published a call
for all public bodies to become
women-friendly workplaces I I lead by
example with gender-specific employment
policies for colleagues experiencing
adverse symptoms of menopause
perimenopause or debilitating
gynological pain
advancing women at every level of the
organization is a key measure of our
corporate success and I've developed a
strategy to support women's development
into leadership positions I'm committed
to addressing the causes of gender pay
in inequity by tackling issues including
paid discrimination recruitment
processes and the support needs of
carers there's still more to be done but
the GLA gender pay Gap has narrowed
since I became mayor it's two percent
compared to the London average of 15.4
percent I published updated equality
diversity and inclusion objectives in
November outlining my plans to advance a
fairer more equal and integrated City
with updated commitments on gender-based
issues making them unsafe for men and
girls is a top priority for me since
2016 I've ever seen investment of over
100 million pounds from City Hall
including 45 million pounds in specially
support for victims and survivors over
35 million pounds in safe accommodation
for anyone who's experienced some
domestic abuse over 70 million pounds in
programs addressing perpetrator Behavior
including pilot in Pilot involving
perpetrators moving out of family home
loss and taking payable change work over
four million pounds in prevention
activities that challenge incorrect
perceptions about what is acceptable
behavior in relationships or in the
public and this includes the one million
pounds to embed a new violence against
women and girls prevention toolkit in
every London primary school I created a
women's Night Safety Charter to make
London a city where all women feel
confident and safe at night especially
in public transport and the London night
SARS prioritized guaranteeing the safety
of women and girls at night since her
appointment we also run several programs
support women's housing needs I
established the domestic abuse safe
accommodation partnership board to fund
provision of support and accommodation
for domestic abuse survivors and my life
of the streets board work to support
women and sleeping rough we've achieved
a lot but there's a lot more to do in
our own committed to challenging
inequality against women and girls at
every level
you um
this said that you agreed with
everything that all the findings from
Louise Casey the Casey report so you
accept the mps's misogynist you say
you've said this morning that you accept
the Vogue strategy Rings Hollow because
that's what she says I mean she says the
Mets Vogue strategy Rings Hollow since
its claim to be priority
prioritizing serious violence has not
really included climb the crimes that
most affect women are girls so
um Dan Casey was very strong about how
badly
uh the mat was doing and after all you
are the police and crime commissioner
and yet if
yet if your tweets
how great I am look what look what I'm
doing I've done a video
um which is one Awards
um to say how wonderful things are what
is it Mr Mayor you're saying
everything's wonderful Louise Casey who
you said just this morning because I was
listening to you that you agree with
everything she says so so what is it are
you wonderful as you'd like us have you
believe or is Dame Louise Casey correct
which I fully accept as has been said
Day news cases uh report she was she was
commented on about Police Service not on
uh City Hall and uh me as a consequence
of Dave news cases report but also the
work that the new commissioner was doing
they are refreshing at having a new
violence against women and girls
strategy and more deals that will be
unveiled surely and also in the
turnaround plan which is being consulted
on there'll be more deals of what
they're doing to address these show
fathers against women and girls
separately separately we have a separate
policy on advancing so many girls
because it's more than just policing so
we do work in relation to shelters in
relation to targeting the behavior of
perpetrators
one of the things we've done with
probation and the police is around GPS
tagging of perpetrators so there are
things we're doing with the police
but the work we do in relation to follow
us against women of girls isn't limited
to policing yeah you can't keep
detaching yourself from the Metropolitan
Police Mr Mayor you are the police and
crime commissioner when it suits you and
things are going well you'll tell us
that everybody that you are the police
and crime commissioner had any other
points and far too frequently you detach
yourself completely in your answer to me
you also say that you've got a night
star or somebody who's looking after
women feeling unsafe after dark I
believe you me we do and yet it's been
found that the extended eulers which we
are so against will force some women out
of their cars because they're
non-compliant and they'll have to be out
in the streets at night
feeling very very unsafe is another
aspect to the US so would you say that
that's a good thing
well there are a number of aspects of
the U.S that will support women
uh so one of the things we know is
consequences of air pollution well can
you deal with what I've said that it
doesn't can we be specific well you're
asking about women's safety I'm actually
saying that the Euless it's been
reported is going to force more women to
use public transport and therefore walk
around after night not feeling safe I'm
a woman I can tell you I do not feel
safe at night sure I was in with women's
safety liquid which was the question you
asked me so we know that women are less
safe because of air pollution uh a
number of a number of specific examples
of where women are let's say because of
air pollution is women who are pregnant
and let's say because of air pollution
women who are driving cars that are
non-compliant are let's say because of
everything yeah as usual you're not
addressing the point and for time
reasons I'll stop there because it's a
complete waste of time you're not
listening to the questions and giving
proper answers to to people that are
listening to this and don't feel safe at
night I'm one of them thank you chair
assembly member Bailey please
morning Mr Mayor
um crime on a tube has risen from 7.5
million crimes per journey in 2016 to
12.1 crimes per million Journeys in 2021
and of course much of these crimes are
directed at women so what are you doing
to make public transport safer for women
so one of the reasons that we began the
campaign when I became in relation to
reported stop it I wanted to encourage
more reporting of things that are
clearly crime but won't be reported
because women didn't think actually were
going to be taken uh obvious thing that
you and I don't experience what women do
is being touched up and sexually
harassed on the tube so that's led to
more women reporting these things and
actually being taken one of the reasons
we introduced reintroduced staff taken
away from the tubes to make sure there
were human beings there to respond to
these uh claims the other thing we did
that directly reflects affects women
using public transport is I supported
the campaign by Gina Martin to make
upskirts in a criminal offense so it's
now criminal offense in this country to
take photographs of women up their
skirts it wasn't until very very uh
recently the other thing we've done is
to make sure that in relation to the
platforms and we've got CCTV coverage of
the platforms and now most of our
training lives as well have CCTV inside
the vehicles and we did more more in
relation to the British Council police
coverage of uh the underground but also
we pay for police officers uh to spend
time policing the underground of public
transport as well you'll be aware that
when the night tube and the overground
began we supported more police officers
around those transport hubs for the
obvious reasons that many women would be
traveling home late at night and may
feel scared and be vulnerable to attack
and so you know the fact that more
people are reporting this is good but
it's no consolation because that means
they're more people are victims of crime
as well so I don't accept the
explanation we should we should welcome
more reporting because it shows more
confidence I think a lot of the more
important is because more women are
facing what HMI say is a national
epidemic of violence against women and
girls
um but so to be clear there's been a
ride from 7.5 million crimes per million
Journeys to 12.1 so 61 rise so many of
the things you've just outlined are
already in place so you could argue are
either ineffective or or are still yet
to be effective so what else can be done
because this is a 61 rise it's a steep
rise and if you continue the way we are
you you'll have no impact it will just
keep going up well report it to stop it
encourage women to report it where they
weren't in the past reporting it so
you're going to see an increase because
people are reporting it with the idea
being to stop it and so we do encourage
people to report these things even if
they think it's not a crime and the more
people report it the more it leads to
action being taken sorry I need to stop
for time for time reasons but reporting
is is still means that crime exists and
somebody needs to do something about it
thank you the next question concerns
adult social care and it's in the name
of assembly member Dr sahota thank you
chair thanks for the question I'm very
disappointed that the government has cut
its promised investment in Social care
Workforce training and development from
500 million pounds to 250 million pounds
this is the last thing we need social
care workers look after our most
vulnerable londoners supporting people
of all ages with a range of conditions
to live their lives with Independence
dignity and control
we'll Democratic due to our social care
Workforce on whom so many londoners
depend with an aging population many
with multiple complex needs it's more
important than ever that social care
workers have the right training to care
with skill and compassion but over the
past 13 years of austerity this
Workforce has been severely neglected
social care is highly skilled and can be
hugely rewarding yet despite the
exceptional service care workers remain
amongst the lowest paid with pay failing
to keep Pace with other sectors
between 2012 and 2022 the vacancy rate
in adult social care in London more than
doubled from 5.9 to 13.2 percent
sickness rates are high in London at 7.5
and across London turnover rates are
over 25 this is a profession under
strain a well-resource social care
system is vital for reducing pressure on
the NHS I'm playing my part by funding
five new social care skills academy hubs
these will help people from
disadvantaged communities into
employment into a sector that's key to
our recovery supporting them via local
training and recruitment into good
social care jobs but I couldn't do so
much the government needs to stop
growing back on its promise to support
this vital Workforce indeed is to
produce a comprehensive social care
Workforce plan that will complement the
still unpublished NHS Workforce plan
uh thank you for that answer Mr Matt of
course the it's double whammy for the
Social Service Services because they the
investment has gone down and secondly
the uniform program that we were
promised for so long has been has been
denied in fact
this is like a old man standing in
middle of the road with a fast
approaching Lorry coming towards him and
the old man hoping that he'll die before
Lori hits him
these aren't my words these are the
words of Andrew Donald the person who
brought the the social form report for
prime minister Cameron
implying that that the social services
now are in the worst state than the the
NHS
and the vacancy rate in London is worse
than the rest of the country the rest of
the country is about 10.5 percent and in
London is 12.8 percent
and so the question is is what can we do
in London
to make the Social Security Services
more attractive to people in London is
there anything we can do from City Hall
Mr Mayor so look firstly thanks for your
question I wasn't aware that Andrew Dawn
had said I said that uh quote uh so it's
appropriate to Performance question I
looked at the last few years in relation
to this area the promises made and rode
back on and this is one example but the
reason why it's so important for us as a
city
it's every single one of us every single
one of us if there's if there's one
issue on this mqts that affect all of us
it's social care
whether presently with some of our
parents or whether it's ourselves
needing social care going uh forward and
at some stage policies in Parliament of
all sides got to get together and make
this cross-party issue it's too
important to be left to one party rather
than the uh either so that being said
and I accept your critique of of
governments inaction from City Hall
we're doing we can in relation to the
skill and labor shortage I mentioned in
my answer some of the social care hubs
that we've set up five new social care
hubs we're working with the NHS in
relation to Health Care hubs to train
people up we've got boot camps to help
people with the skills in this sector
and using some of the aeb money I've got
to be honest though
because the remuneration is not great in
this sector because the terms and
conditions aren't great the stress
levels and so forth question how many
people are thinking about this as a
career going forward or a vacation
vacation going forward that's why we can
do what we can at a regional City level
but we're really into government you
know and it would be great if both both
the main parties all the parties got
together and site working together on
this so whoever wins general election
there is a plan in place that's cross
cross pies support because there are
tough decisions that I have to make now
um although you know we're a young age
City compared to other parts of the
country we've got an Asian population
presents a whole host of opportunities
and challenges
I've been listening this morning and I
can see that the members all over all
sides of the of the debate are concerned
about the cost of living crisis and I
think this is also social care crisis
here maybe we could get together as an
assembly to along with yourself to
campaign for the for this issue
particularly as it has affected
londoners and um and the other thing is
is how can how do you think we can make
this effective
um our representation more effective to
the government what can we do from the
assembly to do that I think we can lead
by example to show the things we can do
in London can make a difference around
the country give you one example which
is a regard from Sutton actually where
Sutton Council had a really good policy
around dementia friendly
and Ruth to leave the council was really
impressive when I first discussed with
her three four years ago and Sweden with
our dementia friendly City
and so a council influencing a city and
if we could do stuff in London from
dementia friendly to social care we can
influence the country as well and so one
of the things that um we're trying to do
is make our city you know more
accessible to older people from dementia
friendly to disabled access to free
access and so forth the fastest growing
age group in London are older londoners
by by 2040 more than 1.6 million will be
above the age of 65 I suspect many of us
by the way are in that category uh I
declare an interest and so we got skill
in the game right but also if we can
show that if we can show Parliament that
we could do something in London it's
like Saturn were quite influential in
London I think we could be influential
with with the government
thank you Mr Bennett
thank you
the next question
uh concerns more rigorous checks for the
London fire brigade employees and it's
in the name of assembly member Clark
thank you thanks for the question
I support the London Fire Commissioners
call for Fire and Rescue Services to
have powers to undertake enhanced DBS
checks for staff the fine rescue service
is the only emergency service that does
not carry out enhanced checks even where
Frontline staff will be working directly
with vulnerable people there's no reason
why the fire rescue service should be an
exception among emerging Services
particularly given the findings of the
inspectorous recent report about
cultural issues that exists across the
service nationally I welcome the recent
Announcement by the government that fire
and Rescue Services will now be able to
carry out standard DBS checks rather
than just basic DPS checks this is a
clear recommendation from the
inspectorate and it was vital that this
change was made quickly however this
changed only the first step and the
government should take forward the
remaining recommendations from the
inspections Report with urgency this
includes amending relevant regulations
So Fire and Rescue Services are able to
undertake enhanced checks like other
emergency services in the February
meeting of the assembly fire resilience
and emergency planning committee the
commissioner referred to examples where
the Brigade has had to dismiss people
who come to the organization who should
never have been appointed this speaks
the fact that Farm Rescue Services need
effective systems in place to prevent
unsuitable job applicants from joining
as we see in other Emergency Services
there are complexities that will need to
be considered around how any new powers
are applied respectively and which staff
they'll apply to these are issues that
affect London alone but should be worked
through a national level there is Need
for consistency have background checks
undertaken across the fire and rescue
service which must bring into line with
other Emergency Services
Mr May and I absolutely agree with you I
think I was surprised to learn
that that the fire service of all the
services Were Somehow exempt from
enhanced DDS checks and you're
absolutely right it's particularly in
light of the culture review and the fire
brigade this is more important than ever
as you said the government are now
moving from basic DBS check to standard
DBS checks should they go further and
move fire and rescue service staff to
the enhanced checks at other blue light
Services have they should and in fact
people won't realize that there are four
levels of DBS check rights you know
basic standard enhanced enhanced with
barred list checks and if you bear in
mind a lot of firefighters will go into
our homes
uh there's been concerns about
inappropriate behavior
um you know and so I think I think by
the commissioner wants it the
commissioner wants it uh you know he's
providing leadership
uh and we should have this around the
country and again another example of us
showing like in London being ahead of
the game we're seeing the police sitting
the fire and you've got an organization
wanting this and so I hope there's
change uh sooner rather than later yeah
thank you for that I mean the
commissioner was very clear when he came
to the prep committee that he wanted for
it he was asking us to work together to
put pressure on government to deliver
this change
um what can the elfb do now to ensure
that they have the highest standards in
the meantime until these measures come
in from the government but there is a
concern that I've got that that because
of the kindness of our commissioner to
do the right thing
will bring in policies that when there's
a national change will be different to
our policy we'll have to do further
checks again so what the commission is
doing is speaking to colleagues around
the country
uh yeah and the relevant um stakeholders
to make sure we can move as one in this
area so in the meantime obviously the
commission is making sure that we are
employing the right people kicking on
the right people still encouraging
people to make complaints if there's
concerns both with the fire service and
members of the public as uh well
um the concern he's got is
um with the best one in the world he
could be missing red flags by having
having the right DBS uh checks as the
veteran I talked about it's too easy to
become a firefighter uh too easy to
become a police officer to get rid of
him and the fire service is it's easy to
get rid of firefighters we don't like
but it still do that proactive work uh
that's important so another commission
is Keen not to do work that will have to
be undone but he's going to move ahead
at PACE to try and persuade College
around the country to move
thank you thank you chair
thank you the next question concerns
trusting the police with expanded Euless
camera data and it's in the name of
assembly member Barry thanks Joe I've
been clear that following Byron's cases
review far rich and reform is needed
within the Met Police Service both
systemically and culturally to regain
the trust of all London's communities in
order to do this the MPS need to
demonstrate they have high standards are
open and transparent and they are truly
accountable to londoners I've already
actually to put the MPS in a path of
systematic and cultural reform with the
appointment of a new commissioner and
leadership team who acknowledge the
scale of the problems and are committed
to change but clearly much more needs to
be done and fast while I'm determined to
hold the commission to account for
reforming the Met Police Service is
vital that we all continue to support
them in their core mission to prevent
anti-tech crime the automatic number
plate recognition system anpr is a vital
tool that assists the police in
identifying location and detaining
offenders including those suspected of
serious organized crime and terrorism
I'm acutely aware of how valuable
personal privacy is and policing Powers
must be balanced against individual your
rights tfl has a range of robust
policies processes and Technical
measures in place to control and
Safeguard the personal data associated
with the camera systems used for Road
charging schemes in London for the
existing agreement with them at Police
Service of data from the current cameras
access to data feeds has to be justified
in a case-by-case basis data is only
stored for 12 months unless it's saved
as evidence for an investigation access
to the data is limited to small number
of specialist staff for a Time limited
period the enhanced conceptual
contextual data the still images are
acquired by law to be of low resolution
to reduce the likelihood that they allow
for the identification of drivers and
passengers together measures like these
provide a safe means of data being
shared with the MPS without jeopardizing
civil liberties there's currently no
decision in place by tearful to Grant
the MPS Access Data from the new Euless
cameras associated with the expansion to
Outer London any future access by the
MPS will need to be in accordance with
data protection requirements and access
only to be granted if the MPS
demonstrates there used to be
proportionate and necessary
okay thank you very much Mr Mayor um so
yes I appreciate you you made a decision
a year ago now to allow tfl camera data
potentially to be given to the Met for
long-term use and storage but I
understand that I think you've just
confirmed that no data sharing
agreements have yet been signed on that
wider Euless zone now I also know that
you're aware there are a number of
potential serious risks to rights from
systems like this and I know you're
aware that since your delegation in
md2977 the Casey review of The Met
police has delivered a damning verdict
on the Mets institutional biases on Race
gender and sexuality in addition
individual misconduct is clearly a
significant problem from the criminal
cases against officers we're seeing
continually in the news I've got a list
here and several of them are worrying
cases that involve the abuse of access
to sensitive data so are you personally
willing today to go on the record to
guarantee that police will be a reliable
competent and trustworthy holder of all
this highly personal and sensitive data
about about londoners that's being
collected by tfl's cameras the police
service is a data controller and so
before the Police Service gets access to
any of the cameras in the expanded
Euless there need to be another data
protection impact assessment and some of
the things you mentioned would be
considered under that and then I'd make
a decision
you know as you said a mirror or
direction if I decided to proceed and
I've said in my main answer the issue is
one of the proportionality of necessity
but the data protection impact
assessment will also be considering
issues that you've raised in relation to
current uh use I've seen in the stuff
the MD I did last year
no evidence of uh no reason not to
continue with and I've added additional
safeguards going forward the abuse you
referred to wasn't in the stuff I saw
last year but if if you know when it
comes to any decision clearly there
needs to be all the information before
me for a requisition
okay thank you um now when we first
corresponded about your decision last
year I was assured that the data
protection issues did need further
consideration and I think again you've
confirmed that now and that the data
protection impact assessments remained
live documents so will you at least meet
with myself and campaigners I'm in
contact with who are working on these
issues and want to discuss them with you
these include open Rights group but also
Grassroots groups working on migrant
rights and racial justice issues if you
would meet with me and those campaigners
to discuss their concerns before you go
any further it would be much appreciated
yeah I should have to give that a second
to meet with the member and the people
she refers to that would be great I'm
glad we're making progress on this issue
Mr Mayor thank you
thank you
um the next question oh I do pick a
pardon assembly member harami thank you
Mr Mayor just on data and Euless cameras
so I sent a freedom of information
request to Brent Council around fly
tipping data around two of the newly
installed cameras from the 2021
expansion and found that there was a 36
drop in fly tipping around one of the
cameras and 24 drop around one of the
others meanwhile in neighboring Harrow
fly tipping is up 30 percent with the
leader of the council even playing the
It Wasn't Me Shaggy card in relation to
a question on the issue even if you
disagree with Euless and you don't want
the 12 000 kilograms of knocks removed
from your air which is the impact in
Harrow should you not at least be
working practically with Transport for
London to agree on camera locations in
your area recognizing the main of the
cameras is to enforce and make sure that
you less is there a successful policy
but actually there's the additional
benefit which could come across from
crime and social behavior and also fly
tipping well I think residents in Harrow
must be pulling their hair out at the
inaction and lack of prioritizing what
residents want them to prioritize so let
me just remind you that rather than how
our council's been in uh you know
taxpayers money to resolve issues around
fly tipping they're using taxpayers
hard-earned money to pay for lawyers to
bring a digital review
against uh you know tfl
and you've seen the difference in
neighboring Brent in relation to action
on fly tipping versus uh Harold in a
good example of the difference having a
good counselor can make
the next question concerns fire safety
and is in the name of assembly member
bakari that's your question I've always
been clear that fire safety is a key
priority in London we owe it to those
who lost their lives in the grenful
tower fire that bereaved and survivors
to ensure a tragedy like that never
happens again
Jim Elvis has worked very closely with
the deputy mayor for Farm resilience and
the Atlanta fire brigade to promote fire
safety helping to keep communities safe
my another plan sets The Benchmark
provides safety in London by requiring
developments to achieve the highest
standards of fire safety the plan puts
London at the Forefront of building
safety nationally for example requiring
the provision of evacuation lifts in all
buildings were left or installed this
ambition was behind my decision earlier
this year to require all planned
applications for residential buildings
over 30 meters in height to be designed
to provide two staircases before they're
referred to the Glo for my decision as
stage two my officers work closely with
developers to implement the requirements
of the London plan and ensure that new
developments coming forward adhere to
these eye standards they're supported in
this by the Brigade specialist fire
engineering team who comment on
development applications in London
through both Planning and Building
regulation consultations my office is
also work closely with the Brigade and
other stakeholders to finalize the
London Fire Safety plan guidance which
will provide further detail for
developers and how to implement the
London plan for fire safety policy for
existing buildings that are already
occupied the brigades inspecting
officers work with responsible persons
and inspect buildings to make sure that
people responsible are maintaining fire
safety measures and meeting the
responsibilities
this is most clearly demonstrated by the
work undertaken on the high rise
building risk review where NFP officers
triage are inspected around 8 000
high-rise buildings across London all
this work is underpinned by the
prevention activities undertaken by the
Brigade to provide safety advice to
londoners about the risk in their homes
including from e-bikes and e-scooters
while the lfp provides a world-class
fire and rescue response we want them to
attend as few fires as possible so this
prevention work is crucial to help
people take steps at home to keep
themselves safe
thank you um you'll be aware that the
top story on BBC London this morning is
on yet another e-scooter fire this time
in Brent in January 2022 when I first
asked you about a public awareness
campaign on on safe lithium iron
batteries and then I followed that up
again in October again I asked you about
plans that you had to tackle on this
particular issue and at the same time
alongside liberal Democrat MPS I wrote a
number of times to government ministers
about this building safety and fire risk
for londoners over a year and a half
later the lfb have now started their
vital public awareness campaign charge
safe but after meetings with the lfb
they know that this isn't enough have
you personally contacted government
ministers during the last 12 months
calling on them to bring in regulations
to tackle the issue of lithium ion
battery related fires record my thanks
to Chris philp the minister for police
in crime and uh fire who's been
assiduous and respond to my concerns so
what Chris has done is arranged for the
lfb to meet with the office for product
safety and standards
who will bring forward a proposal around
product safety so the issue is in
relation to online sales the issues in
relation to uh conversions and
um it Chris has moved fast on this issue
and the role that Commissioners briefed
him and uh so we are working with the
government of this uh we should be
personally writing as well because it's
responding is
I mean the government's responding so
I'm not sure what the purpose of that
would be so to give Chris apart on the
back which I hate doing uh if I can
avoid it and so the key thing is look
there are loopholes here and there are
fires happening somebody lost their life
on this issue and the government
recognizes and the five minutes and
recognizes the loophole he's listened to
the Commissioners our views on this and
there should be some movement but I'd
say to anybody watching this
um you know be very conscious when you
when you're charging your e-bike
e-scooter if you've got if you're if
you're if you're if your bike or scooter
is a conversion or buying stuff online
you could be buying stuff that's very
dangerous yeah and I mean the change so
save came pain has to be a success we
need to reduce these fires and help
londoners buy Safe products from
reputable companies but until there is
government intervention particularly
with on sale online sales this will be
really really challenging for the London
fire brigade to do this on its own now
you've mentioned the government but we
also need you as well to take some
charge and Lead here will you help by
looking at a mayoral kite Mark for
companies that sell e-scooters and
e-bikes that promote the change charge
safe public awareness messages for
maintenance and charging we've spoken to
experts in New York uh where they're
ahead of us in relation to this issue
and nobody suggested the experts I've
spoken to a regional kind mark would be
a way to resolve this particularly with
online sales and so that's why we're
working with the government relation to
the office for product safety and
standards to discuss what can be done to
address these uh concerns but if it was
the case anybody suggested a regional
Kai mark would somehow stop online sales
from often at the far East or then have
took into this but you know it's
reasonable when it's remember the public
about the consequences of batteries
conversion kits e-scooters and e-bikes
that's why we fully support the charge
safe campaign from led by the lfp I mean
I I want the government to do more but
so can you and I think this is a really
good step forward if you were to do your
mayoral kite mark it would make a
difference and I think that's something
that we could be doing to help londoners
make sure that they're safer we don't
want any more deaths related to this
these types of fires
foreign
the next question concerns cookering by
assembly member uh Desai thank you chair
cocoon is a horrific form of
exploitation which these vulnerable
people being taken advantage of by drug
dealers who coerce or violently force
them into having their homes taken over
for the purpose of the Dealer's business
we know that many of the adult victims
of cocoon are people with complex needs
including drug addiction and mental
health issues taking a Polish approach
is vital in tackling this form of
exploitation the MPS is dedicated cocoon
officers who work with local Authority
housing teams adult safeguarding mental
health and drugs treatment services to
ensure vulnerable people are safeguarded
and diverted from the criminal justice
system where possible that Police
Services introduced new processes and
offers a training to better recognize
and record instances of cocoon last year
there were 179 crime reports which were
given this marker my London drugs forum
which brings criminal justice health and
local Authority Partners together to
reduce drug-related harms and crimes is
examining how they can enhance the work
already underway to address this issue
The Forum will also be looking later in
the year at the problems faced by drug
users with multiple and complex needs
which will include addressing how we can
protect the most vulnerable people from
this type of from this type of
exploitation and the London crime
prevention fund provides boroughs with
the opportunity to lead local work to
support vulnerable people at risk of
exploitation including funding a post to
address this issue in Camden I'm
committed to tackling the harms that
result from drugs having invested four
million pounds into project Adder to
support prevention diversion and local
engagement
today I released my report on cooking in
London
um I'm glad that you defined what
cooking is
it has a terrible impact on some of the
most vulnerable londoners my report is a
comprehensive snapshot of cooking across
London it makes 10 recommendations but I
would like to highlight two in
particular reporting and making it
offense as reported in the evening
surrendered to death and earlier I think
you said there are some good reporters
on the evening standard
the report shows that there's been a
significant rise in cooking cases a 300
percent increase if we compare 2018 to
2022 despite some improvements there's
still an uneven recording of cooking
across the capital which suggests the
true figure may be higher
cooking is a sharp focus it is currently
under reported and we need to raise
public awareness of the issue so my
question Mr Mayor is will you look into
how Mopac can work with the MPS local
authorities to improve awareness of this
issue
yeah
for those watching this is another
example of the good work the assembly
does the report that you've done today
in relation to this really important
issue I think you're right by the way in
your
your view that there's probably a huge
Under reporting so you're almost 200
increase maybe an underestimate which is
really scary I'm more than happy to give
you that commitment and that undertaking
it's really important issue but also for
the London drugs forum to also consider
a lot of recommendations you make
particularly in relation to the gaps in
data and how data sharing could really
make a difference in this area
in a report by the center for social
justice senior cross party MPS including
Jess Phillips and Ian Duncan Smith
called upon the government to make
cooking an offense uh in the in the
modern slavery act this is a call I
support
uh in my report noting that there's a
lack of guidance or even a definition
from the government in dealing with
cooking
would you consider writing to the Home
Secretary to support these calls given
cooking's terrible impact as I said
earlier on vulnerable londoners which I
want to agree to read the the report and
then write to the government just to
just remind colleagues that the modern
slave react was only passed in 2015 and
I think the intention was always there'd
be they'd be evolving new forms of
slavery it's called the modern slavery
act and this may be one one area which
which is worth the government looking
into as an area of evolving exploitation
slavery of vulnerable people and so I'm
more than happy to read the report and
then write to colleagues in government
to to Lobby them about this thank you Mr
Mayor they'll say there are another
eight recommendations but um I'll let
you read the report and come to your own
conclusions thank you again Mr Mayor
and it is very common I I personally I
have the case only the the uh two days
ago that that involved involved this
it's extraordinarily common so good to
remember to for raising that thank you
um
the next question is tfl's Workforce
relations and its name in the name of
assembly member Baker thank you Joe
thanks for the question in August tfl
reached agreement with the government on
a funding settlement for tfl which will
last until the 31st of March 2024 or
until tearful which is Flash
sustainability depending on what you see
now
the funding settlement place the number
of requirements on tfl including them
raising revenue and pension reform on
the 14th of October October 2022 tearful
submitted a pensions options paper to
the government this was a direct
response to the requirement of the deal
to consider options to reform the TFO
pension discussions between TFO and the
government remain ongoing no changes to
the tfl pension are currently being
proposed if any changes were to be
proposed in the future tfl would consult
fully with affected members and their
representatives as appropriate it
remains tfl's position that any changes
would not have any impact on benefits
built to date there is no denying that
the future funding agreement and its
Associated requirements have put
increased pressure on tearful and its
Workforce including on morale I
repeatedly made clear that the
government's insistent insistence on
including a review into pension and
reform was unwarranted another potential
to lead to Industrial action table is
committed to working positively with its
staff and unions last year over 15 000
tierville staff participated in the tfl
Viewpoint survey which our staff to
reflect on their experience of working
at tfl
can I just
uh there was a there were many many
deadlines in those
um funding agreements there was a
deadline around a final proposal on tfl
pension reform that was the 28th of
February was there any progress
um or so it sounds like there was an
agreement could you just uh so so the
lines written for me by the civil
servants or discussions are ongoing
fantastic I'm sure there are
um
um so and I really appreciate and feel
for tfl they're in a very difficult
situation
um in terms of the cost of funding that
have been uh forced on them by those
funny agreements from the government
um I am concerned that there may be some
unintended consequences coming out of
them and so I'd like to raise a couple
of those with you one of which is that I
understand a revised consultation and
Collective redundancy process is uh is
being tabled by Transport for London and
the concerns will be raised to me that
this is a watered-down version
um of of what was a very comprehensive
process previously and the danger with
my view the danger with water dam
proposals is that especially in the
context where we've lost a lot of
talented tfl staff that you can end up
losing people when you don't go through
full processes to understand what the
implication of of cutting staff is
um could you ask can you commit to ask
the deputy mayor for transport to take a
close interest in the industrial
relations and particularly in this
process yeah I'm more than happy to and
that member raises are really important
unintended consequence of some of these
uh changes if not done properly so I'm
more than happy to commit to the deputy
mayor being closely involved with any
proposed organizational changes but also
the wider policy review process as well
that's that's very welcome thank you and
and the other other possibly unintended
consequence that I'd like to raise is
around Savings in bus operations so
um obviously the tendering process that
is based around the uh the routes that
are going out to Tender
um but I am perhaps concerned that
because those actual savings will be
carried out by the bus operators that
again tfl may have that what the impact
is slightly at arm's length
um are you are you um have tfl given you
any assurance that there won't be
unintended consequences in terms of
Workforce
um Workforce relations Workforce
conditions and also service quality
um in as a result of those savings
um and can we have some sort of further
information on on how to assure that
yeah
really partnership has been raised one
of the reasons for our concern about the
lack of
a a funding deal and lack of certainty
around capital is that inability to make
the long-term deals with the private
sector including bus operators and so
I'm sure it wasn't the government's
intention but a consequence of these
short adult deals is we've had to do
short last minute doors with bus
operates paying more than we otherwise
would and having a long-term capital
domains we can make long-term cheaper
deals because they're seven years eight
years and so forth it benefits the
taxpayer and also the bus user as well
as the company and the drivers and so
forth but you're right we've got to make
sure that the way bus operators don't
make us save it is at the cost of the
driver which can which can then have a
knock-on effect in relation to bus
passengers so it's a producer and a
consumer interest you'll be aware you
know since I've been there we've
massively improved you know the there's
a minimum wage for bus drivers better
terms and conditions and so forth and
you're right we've got a be cognizant
about an unintended way of saving money
but in sacrificing service and also the
way our bus drivers are treated you know
with you I was at recent Memorial to
commemorate those who lost their lives
during the pandemic and the worst thing
we could do is their families is you
know have current bus drivers treated
worse than their loved ones were so you
know I promised you is to make sure we
don't inadvertently have a situation
where either bus drivers suffer or the
service suffer but I will again Ask sept
to look into this just just to build
some braces to make sure we've not
missed anything
be very grateful for that thank you very
much
I would now like to
ask your agreement if the assembly will
agree to suspend standing order 2.9 B in
accordance with the provisions of
standing order 1.1 H in order to allow
the remaining business on the agenda to
be completed
yeah nobody nobody's ever been against
that
um but thank you very much yeah that's
because the matters of a vote well I
used to vote against it actually but
anyway the next
um the next Quest question is concerned
the child-friendly city and it's in the
name of assembly member Sheikh thanks
the question I've been clear that London
must support children and young people's
independent Mobility that's why the
first of my London plans good growth
objectives is building strong and
inclusive communities this sets an
objective for all londoners including
children and young people to be able to
move around the city with ease and
confidence to enjoy the opportunities
London offers my London plan includes
specific policies that promote the
provision of safe and accessible routes
to schools such as through linking
cycling and walk-in networks and the
provision of accessible routes to youth
centers and play spaces plays crucial to
the children's well-being and
development the London plan requires
residential schemes to provide at least
10 square meters of good quality
accessible play provision per child
which should be safely and independently
accessible and not segregated by tenure
large polygram schemes are expected to
provide spaces for play and informed
Recreation and borrowers are required to
incorporate this expectation into their
local plans my public land Charter and
draft loan plan guidance and housing
design standards provide further details
on the provision of plain informal
Recreation space and by making London
child-friendly report supports the
assessment of public run spaces to
ensure they're safe and accessible thank
you Mr Merton absolutely I do enjoy
reading your making London
child-friendly report the forward
written by my colleague assembly member
McCartney I think you've definitely got
a handle on this agenda I mean I was
shocked to understand that you know
between 1971 and 20 2010 children being
able to walk to school alone decrease
from 86 to 25 whilst we saw child
obesity increase you know the ability
for children to feel safe and free
um and a crucial part of their emotional
development is the idea of being able to
have that independent mobility and this
has already been compounded during the
pandemic the kind of the limitations on
it so I was wondering if you could just
drill down a little bit more about what
increased challenges since the pandemic
we face in terms of making our City
child friendly it's a really interesting
start you you you you you just mentioned
about the the fact that fewer people are
walking towards by themselves you know
um
and so one of the things we've tried to
do is work with great councils like uh
the first one we worked with was Camden
Camden in 2017. had the first school
street in London
we'd had more than 500
um all across London and the reason why
school streets are important is because
they provide a safe environment for
children to walk school to cycle to
school with Mom Dad or Keira which is
one of the big concerns families have
about safety road safety of children and
the good news is post the pandemic
there's been an acceleration of school
streets across our city the concern was
after the pandemic people jump back in
their cars which is a problem we want to
try and avoid where it's possible to
walk cycle use public transport the
other big concern we've got a relation
to
um uh children safety is where to play
and so during the pandemic you know kids
were basically locked away in very
commas for like you know a year
definitely during those three months
during the enforced lockdown and some
children weren't socialized to play
publicly
they call them covered babies and stuff
so we're trying to do we can with
nurseries and others to make sure we
have children who who may have been
affected by the pandemic help relation
to play spaces hand-eye coordination and
other things we're not directly
responsible for this we can create an
environment where you know children do
so thank you very much and obviously at
the beginning of the mqt we heard about
the support and the encouragement and
the guidance that you're providing
councils in order to increase uh the
units of family-sized homes that they
build but I wanted to ask you a little
bit more about what you're doing to push
developers on this and not just on
family size homes but also ensuring that
play spaces aren't segregated by tenure
it's a really important point in
relation to what we can do directly to
influence development and the obvious
thing is the London plan
so the learner plan has policies in
place in relation to a range of
accommodation sizes in relation to play
space in relation to public Realm uh and
you mentioned the issue of uh you know
the tenure so that includes so the homes
that we've recently been visiting uh
with with Tom uh Copley are homes which
are which you couldn't tell from the
home or the door if it was a council
flat or a council home or shared
ownership or you know private sector
market value and the same should go for
playgrounds and so forth and access to
these uh facilities and so it's really
important that we think about that and
by the way also we've also got charts in
place now for private lands that are
public spaces you remember the old city
hall a lot of that land outside wasn't
owned by uh the the public was owned by
a private landlord and there are all
strict rules about who do what in the
private space we've made sure outside
this city hall that it is public run a
available to the public without too many
restrictions and I have to say I've seen
whether that's young families or dogs or
people sunbathing enjoying the public
space outside so I absolutely think that
agenda is being pushed forward thank you
very much Mr Mayor
thank you
um the next question concerns outer
London public transport improvements
it's in the name of assembly member
Prince no time is short I'm happy to
send him the answer and he can ask me
something questions about AIDS
a very grateful to you Mr Mayor thank
you very much
um where I'm trying to go with this is
the super Loop which you announced a few
weeks ago doesn't get into havering at
all
and because the shortage of time I was
wondering whether you'd be prepared to
have a meeting or your Deputy Mayor to
have a meeting on how we can improve
transport links in havering which I'm
always very happy to uh uh meet with
senate members I'll ask or ask WBS to
our last step to meet with Keith in the
first instance in relation to haverin
and the super Loop to see if we can make
progress there thank you and and also
you did at the last meeting agree to
meet with me regarding wanstead let's
just let me check out follow that up
after this meeting that's cool thank you
then you want to talk for eight seconds
no okay
I would
um the um
the next question uh is refers to
trusting the police with live facial
recognition technology and assembly
member Russell to ask that question
thank you chip Barons Casey said in a
review that we give the police
exceptional Powers we trust them to use
them responsibly clearly this package
has been shaken and there's now
considerable work the MPS must do to
regain the trust of londoners just not
the time I'm happy to send you the
answer on you uh Mr Mayor actually I'd
really like to hear your full answer on
the record today um I don't think we've
got time to actually get into
questioning thanks Karen rebuilding
trust in policing is crucial and the MPS
must show how they are treated all
London is fairly live facial recognition
was not mentioned in baroness cases
report but following the review it's
right that all aspects of MPS operations
are reflected on the commissioner will
soon be published in his revised
turnaround plan set the path for the
future of the MPS the appropriate use of
live facial recognition can Aid the
police by locating wanted offenders
including high-risk individuals
identifying suspected terrorists and
locating vulnerable visuals ultimately
helping to keep our communities safe but
this tool must of course come with a
robust scrutiny accountability and
transparency and impartial and
evidence-based analysis of Life facial
recognition by the national physical
laboratory has provided Assurance around
the accuracy of the technology included
in relation to demographic dysportality
the London Police and ethics panel has
reported on live face recognition and
developed five conditions to ensure MPS
deployments follow ethical guidance
which the MPS will comply with to a
transparency the MPS has published a
considerable amount of information about
live facial recognition on its website
including the legal framework impact
assessments and unethical review the MPS
has also had regular engagement with a
wide range of oversight bodies academic
institutions Civil Society organizations
and Independence advisors the green
group is now out time
question
is in the name of assembly member harani
and it concerns centralized funding and
Power thanks for the question the UK is
one of the most centralized countries in
the world and London has limited control
over the taxes raised in the capital the
only funding we have control over is
raised through a levy on council tax and
a supplementary levy on business rates
by contrast New York has local control
over funds from residential and
non-residential property taxes sales and
related taxes and revenues from income
taxes is similar story for Paris and
Tokyo and the UK these funds are spent
by remote Whitehall departments
decentralization leads to London being
pitted against other cities in
competitive bids for funding pots that
waste time and resources for example
recent unsuccessful bids for Enterprise
zones cost London government in the
region of fifty thousand pounds the
rules about what you can spend the money
on the timetable forbidden the formats
for bids and the selection criteria and
processes all vary from One Fund to
another and the spend incisions made
often perverse it was reported last year
that some of the wealthiest parts of
England had been allocated 10 times more
money per capita than the poorest under
inverted commas leveling up funds we've
been given extra Powers we've delivered
I've learned a substantial increase in
affordable housing and exceeded skills
targets two areas where budgets have
been devolved to be
foreign
thank you and I'm uh glad you recognized
the issue about the funding impact on
not just the GLA but councils across the
country because instead of spending
money on core Services they're having to
spend money on bid writing or offices I
happen to spend time in addition to the
actual job what is the impact on the
need to having to apply for funding
having on the GLA so so I gave evidence
to the select committee on this very
issue and I made the point that not only
are council's spending a huge amount of
energy effort time and money on these
bids but we obviously work with councils
and so we Quantified the cost to London
and bear in mind of the 139 borrowers
that were successful 139 borrowers
successful only five one on the
borrowers so I spent a huge amount of
time effort money uh office of time but
also we're raising expectations that
we're going to get this money and we
don't and so we said to the government
that the far better of doing this is
block contracts over the longer term
rather than you know sort of a Hunger
Games of metro news and local
authorities which just seems nonsensical
to us
thank you a report last year I found
that the UK is more centralized than any
comparable country and the centralized
power leads to an unbalanced economy
given what we are experiencing in the in
the economy at the moment do you agree
that local councils and the GLA should
have greater powers on what happens
locally in their area rather than
decisions being made at Whitehall the
best of course but based on the evidence
I've had for the last seven years based
I mentioned to answer just two areas
where that you can see the progress
we've made by being in charge of it
skills
we in London work really closely with
the Fe sector with local authorities but
also with businesses working at what
where is the skill shortages so we can
have our colleges and academies
providing those skills for jobs that are
future proof far better student than
civil servants in the DFE in white Soul
the same goes in relation to talking to
developers and councils and how
associations in relation to housing
starts and so forth so you know the
government said a few years ago that
they would use a sucker NC in relation
to Devolution which show we can do it by
the way Andy Burnham greater Manchester
nurses Community far better than civil
service in whitechall or Andy Street in
West Midlands or you know Ben Halton in
tease Valley or Steve Rotherham in
Liverpool so my point to the government
is uh you know I say this whoever the
government was if there's a labor
government issue also the same to the
local government you know give powers
and resources away to Citizen regions
across the country we know our patch
with respect to far better than you do
thank you another area that has come to
my attention uh due to local case work
is around the education sector where
academies are centrally funded and
answerable to the department for
Education by contrast schools that are
funded by local authorities are
obviously answerable to them and that
has had a knock-on impact on admissions
in 2009 2010 there were 203 academies
across England and in 2021-22 there were
uh
9628 which is a rise of 4 700 percent uh
this has led to particularly my
constituency uh having an impact on
admissions where uh depending on where
people live they are being excluded on
every single category priority category
for schools in the area they live do you
what are your views on the
decentralization agenda of this
government and the impact that it's
having on families in London
put aside what you think of our
Academy's free schools or whatever the
lack of coordination is causing real
problems
I'll give you some examples of another
other examples you mentioned the lack of
coordination in admissions which means
families are missing out on going to you
know the school they want to go to
different schools because of the academy
system difficult to call in relation to
working together with their own
exclusions
in relation to keeping children in
schools in relation to provision of
physical meals in relation to after
school clubs in relation to school
support offices so this you know
disparate atoms of units we've got of
schools is causing raw challenges and
the whole host of societal problems and
I think you know I think the
government's got to realize that they've
you know I'm sure it wasn't an intended
consequence because they're all
challenges in communities who see the
school as their local school but it's an
local control of the councilors or the
local mayor
example that those executive Mayors and
even the MP and so it really is
important the government understands the
lack of accountability of these atoms of
schools this calling and stuff and so
I'd like to be better coordination I
mean the VOE has done a great job in
some areas there's so many other areas
we do some great work with the academies
and The Umbrellas and the trust but it's
very hard
assembly member best
the most concerned about council's
bidding for funding will he abolish that
process within the GLA
there's plenty of time to give an answer
so
um the next question you've been smoking
today Tony
the next question
is for research purposes yeah
I was talking about
you've been in Canada recently have you
the last uh the last question calm down
we'll be over soon and you can go Andrew
Scully you should be nice
um the um
the um
next question Neil who are you back in
the next question is about heat pumps
and it's from assembly member Cooper
thank you chair sadly nowhere in the UK
is making enough progress on heat pumps
in London our preferred Pathways to
hitting at zero by 2030 requires a
significant transformation
towards the electrification and
decarbonization of heat but this
transformation can only be delivered
with greater national action required
significantly more investment by
government and the private sector
the government must implement the
recommendations of the Skidmore review
ensuring at least 600 000 heat pumps are
installed nationally each year by 2028.
this will be achieved more efficiently
by devolving funds and Powers through
London planned policies I secured the
installation of heat pumps saving over
23 000 homes in 2021 up from 13 400 in
2020. my retrofit accelerators in the
mayor's Energy Efficiency fund have
supported the development and
installation of heat pumps within
existing homes and workplaces in
southwark at the mayor's Energy
Efficiency fund funded a heat pump
system for over two thousand dwellings
if my green skills hubs and academies
are helping grow the decarbonization
supply chain needed to support the
successful deployment of heat pumps with
32 million pounds spent on green skills
in 2122 but we need more action from the
government through National installation
and retrofit schemes better regulation
and crucially rebalancing of domestic
energy bills Shifting the cost of
decarbonization thank you very much Mr
Merrell I'm actually going to loop back
to
um what assembly member Polanski was
talking about right at the top of this
mayor's question time which was the
recent figures that have just come out
talking about how we are now very likely
to exceed the 1.5 degrees in in the next
two or three years which is uh really
concerning you had a report that came
out at the beginning of uh 2022 that
said that we need to scale up and be
installing 2.2 million heat pumps by
2030 so with the best will in the world
although you're doing a lot we are
absolutely nowhere near that we heard
from Community energy London yesterday
that they think only 12 heat pumps were
installed in in Westminster
um in the in the last year what more can
we do in terms of lobbying the
government for some sort of incentives
to really get going in terms of heat
pump installations for those
householders who can afford to think
about moving away from gas spoilers
themselves
the frustration is look even people who
want to do the right thing can't afford
15 000 pounds which is the average
of heat pump heat pump installation
uh when I look at countries like Germany
so Germany each year each year is
spending
between 13 and 14 billion pounds each
year on heat pumps 13 to 14 billion
pounds we're spending 450 million pounds
so that shows a difference it's not on
the page are we but but they're creating
jobs yeah they're addressing the climate
emergency they're creating jobs both in
terms of making these heat pumps the
workforce installing the heat pumps and
they're saving bills for those who've
got heat pumps uh installs and I I can't
for the life of me understand why the
government doesn't recognize the
opportunity created by the crisis that
is a client emergency even if they came
up with a system that's similar to
something like the
um system where somebody gives a grant
at the beginning and then from the
savings that you make in your bills you
then start to re-pay some of the the
costs the the grant you've been given
well you'll remember a few years ago
they got rid of the feeding tariff
certainly did so so you know I think to
to quote a former prime minister a
conservative one inverted commas Green
Crack right and we're paying the
consequences of those policies uh a few
years ago because we've got this crisis
with you know Putin invading Ukraine
illegally a massive increase in the cost
of uh you know fossil fuels had we
invested in Renewables had we had things
like the feeding tariff heat pumps hey
people would struggle would be
struggling that's with the cost of
living crisis but also would be
addressing the climate agency
what about people who are in the private
rented sector is there something that
can be done to encourage private
landlords to think more about getting
rid of gas boilers and replacing them
with heat pumps is there some sort of
incentive that could be brought in there
as well I think it is difficult with uh
those landlords who are private
landowners who want to do properties
it's just typical because it costs so
much for the heat pump where we are
making work is a relation to Municipal
landlords I mentioned the example in
South Africa 2000 dwellings we're
working with credits on a Housing State
there as well so I think private
landlords without government support is
very hard to support them and some
private owners want to do the right
thing right but they can't afford to
spend 50 000 pounds on a heat pump so
we're focusing the mayor's Energy
Efficiency fund on bigger units of homes
for obvious reasons and that's why I'm
saying look at what Germany's doing
Germany has a culture where more people
rent than our own rocket prize here
they're making massive progress by
contributions from the government and
you know a bit more of that and by the
USA is doing something similar in
relation to support for uh businesses
but also families as well thank you very
much Mr Miller let's hope we can scale
up from hundreds of millions to billions
as we need to thank you Jeff
that was the last question so can I ask
the assembly to agree the motion which
is set out here on the agenda in my name
which is that the assembly notes the
answers to the questions asked
[Applause]
great
date of next meeting the next scheduled
meeting of the London assembly will be
the plenary meeting which will take
place at 2PM this afternoon
so soon in the chamber here at City Hall
and we
as chair of there is no urgent business
requiring consideration therefore I'll
draw the meeting to a close thank you
very much thank you Mr Mayor